hello
[Music]
[Applause]
we are all domestic terrorists that's
right ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists
I got myself a tasty coffee with that
flavored cream in it yeah it goes good a
little different flavors dude I feel
like the skinnier you get the better you
get at debates and um you've owned me
too hard I'm you know let's just get it
out of the let's just
let's just start off by saying you know
this is the last episode of leftovers
yeah after our last episode yeah in the
heated
uh debate that we had I realized that I
was a class Trader
and that I don't know why people said
that because like that's a good thing in
your situation to be a pleasure like I
don't think they meant it like that yeah
like that doesn't make any sense I like
what you're saying though like you'd be
like angles you know what I mean like
the guy who who co-authored it and and
was like facilitating it but also like
had a factory you know what I mean so
that's not a bad thing angles is a class
Trader that's right that's me I'm angles
oh yeah definitely but um there was
there was crazy Fallout for my last
episode which is kind of nuts because
you know I will ignoring all that though
it seemed like a lot of people did like
the conversation I myself am pretty
ignorant on the methods of governing and
uh histories and all that so I do think
this conversation of I'm not even gonna
say capitalism because that seems to
trigger people I'm just gonna say social
democracy because people hear me say
capitalism they [__] their [__]
britches yeah because there's a lot of
well first of all we're online so no
matter what you say people are gonna be
very passionate about it one of the
things that I do quite frequently
is yell at people to be normal because
people just have no [__] way of being
normal online
so there's that problem and then the
other side of it is like there's a lot
of uh you know baby socialists out there
who are like on their own Journey okay
and they get like really passionate
and and the the goal always is like oh
my God we have to convert every single
person to socialism
immediately or anyone in the right of me
is part of the problem there's that too
but of course you know
um
it's uh it takes a while it takes a
while to to engage in uh
any kind of movement building and it's
something I stress quite a bit it's hard
to tell how much of it was
um anyway regardless I I was actually
invigorated by the conversation and that
you know
I I I don't know what I'm talking about
and so I've been thinking about our
conversation a lot and I've been
educating myself a lot and I want to
continue the conversation today but I
don't want to have a debate I want to
have like a
I want to go on a
a fact-finding journey for myself about
how socialism is addressing certain
issues versus social democracy okay and
to understand from you a socialist
mm-hmm
um
what what really that is and how how
would it be you know interactive Dan are
you a socialist would you say
I I broadly so I'd say so sure
dude we're about to get executed after
this Ethan's called dude everybody was
riding for you guys this is Ethan's uh
McCarthy trials
it's like would you say you're a card
carrying communist okay very good no
being a socialist is cool apparently
online no dude it's it's like there are
right well it's super cool it is for as
many as many like very little well of
course there's a lot of people here
there's a lot of people here that would
be uh like there are very few places
online where you can just be like out
and about and openly uh defend uh any
kind of economic organization Society
Beyond capitalism uh without a
tremendous amount of scrutiny
um well I got roses Dogma well of course
the other the other side was defending
you that's why you didn't notice it you
know that's not good though I don't want
Tim pulled defending me or whatever
whoever I didn't watch all I didn't
watch all the no I I don't think Tim
poodle absolutely but one of his one of
his one of his uh Commanders
the guy who's like always the the really
weird like failed musician guy that I
think describes all of them yeah but
true but um I want to better represent
my position uh because I didn't I don't
really know a lot and I feel like I've
done a lot of research in the week uh
following the conversation so what did
you do what did you read
what kind of research I had a very
in-depth conversation with Chad gbt
that's good I got I got I asked it
really kind of well baseball thinks it's
social like chat gbt socialist so like
church people probably chatting right
yeah yeah that gbd keeps it so real yeah
Lenin pilled you so no is Lenin a
socialist or a Social Democrat no that's
Lenin is is uh
the Revolutionary figure that is
probably more important than than Marx
even
his deal he's just so he's just a
socialist yes he's the first like I mean
this is where the the the father of the
USSR
that was a nice that was a nice Legacy
to have
could have been I'm just kidding I'm
sorry no no no no no no no no you're no
there's there's nothing I don't think
it's that controversial to say that like
yeah I mean USSR Orwell Joseph Stalin
was basically right whatever that's not
what I want to get into right now Stalin
definitely had a lot of issues I will
admit first I want to say
that I promote my [__] all the time on
the show so now I want to give Hassan a
shout out I can't there's no reason to
promote her he's already all sold out oh
it is yeah good for you new ideology
drop immediately sold out kind of
annoying that it sold out so quick but
I'm sorry except for the hoodie that I'm
wearing currently that's it
um which one is that this one cost anger
management one
yeah
get the president on the phone quick no
I don't want to hear it
no yeah that's the Vibes Buy It Now
nice good for you scum capitalist scum I
[__] love it dude I'm just kidding I
know you work with unionized people for
that
of course teddyfresh.com is that sale
going on
uh support my exploited workers today
still
it's an ongoing most of it is gone but
it's worth the brows
all right so I don't do all this new
[__] I want to get straight into it oh I
have a separate dock okay damn damn
that's why I didn't see it hold on this
man this man has his own dock dude oh
well no because I put yeah you got some
notes that's fair what email is this I
say let the conversation begin
all right let me just share while you're
looking for that though it doesn't chat
CCP chat CCP that's good that's really
good that's funny I I love that I'll
just announce some uh breaking news I
saw right before we went live but
Rupert our boy died it did not die yeah
he died
but he has stepped down the Rupert
Murdoch era is officially over I've seen
enough uh secession to know that that's
he's going to come back
that's actually not a bad assessment
he's not going to leave yeah Lachlan is
the fail son he's not sure hold the
[__] pull through yeah it's [__]
where's my document dude first he got
cucked by Tucker Carlson and then like
had to divorce his the like fiance that
he was gonna get married to and now he's
like leaving his Empire behind what's
happening in a rope Ruby You've Lost
Your Touch brother
that's what he wants to do in his
retirement yeah he wants to go out with
style okay here it is I found it that
would be so much better than than
whatever the [__] he did up until this
very moment slow crack and die
and just like go out and style you don't
even need to die just like have gay sex
do crack you know I would do hair in my
retirement what am I doing heroin right
just to ease out just be you know just
[__] because like who cares if you
get all strung out and it's like who
gives a [__] you're like you you're
making an argument you're making the
best of your time you're making an
argument for palliative care which I
feel like
um it's like end of life like death care
basically
um Hospice Care they do that no I I feel
like there's going to be there's this
assessment
from economists that there's going to be
a major and it's already started a major
boom in the like uh geriatric care and
palliative care all the boomers are done
um because like the last like what you
would consider middle class uh of
America is all in the Boomer side
I mean Boomer like in a boomer Zoomer
terminology I mean like anyone over the
age of [__] 50 like actual baby
they're not actually some of them are
baby boomers
um
but uh they are all the people that are
like desperately holding on to like
whatever assets they have remaining yeah
so now they have money and you have
they're the only people that have money
so you have to figure out how to like
meet their needs how do we get it from
them by insanely expensive we should
make a hospice show like that we should
get their money bro oh yeah jack up the
price
get all that money no that's my money
give it to me bro here take this take
this fentanyl shut the [__] up yeah I
feel like that would be that would be
pretty fire though like what you're
saying no but seriously what's the
drawback to just going full heroin
because listen there's a reason people
get addicted to it because it's it's
good it's fun well wouldn't you argue
that morphine might be better but like
there's massive Concepts yeah it's the
same joke right in a way it's just a
matter of intensity there's no drawback
because obviously you don't want to be
an addict during you know the middle of
your life you have so there's so much
you need to do and here being a heroin
addict is just not compatible with
living a normal life but if you're in a
retirement home
then I feel like it's also more ethical
than the way that they currently operate
those places because it's like full of
[__] theft and like
is making a cleaning dude she's doing
all these Elderly Homes
anyway let's move on let's get out of
office we have a lot to discuss
but we should get into that but like run
an elderly care yeah facility and then
all the fans can send their parents yeah
and we'll kick it back to them and we'll
just [__] give him heroin and then
yeah the goal is we take kill the half
The Inheritance we take half of the
inheritance and then the other half goes
to the to the children it goes back to
them because they were going to get that
and that way it doesn't even get hit by
the estate tax because we already
[__] taxed them I found it boom
genius [__] all right first I want to
make this clear capitalism is not
Innovative but we just innovated under
capitalism
I agree so [__] true that's the
entrepreneurial spirit I agree
by the way garyvee is going to do this
yo I've got a great idea let's make nft
Critters out of your dead grandparents
you guys bro you know yeah I saw it I
saw like uh statistic I don't know how
[__] true it is but like I mean it
feels very real 95 of the nft
marketplace is now zero dollars like
it's collapsed it is so crazy how none
of those people none of those [__]
charlatans that were advocating for this
[__] and trying to get you to hold the
goddamn bag have been punished for it
including Gary vaynerchuk as a matter of
fact so man real quiet on the V friends
from perspectives dude it's like it
should be studied how fast the media
jumped on that train and was like or at
least alternative media Outlets have you
considered this jumped on it and we're
like pushing for it have you considered
this fortune favors the brave don't show
that to me I'm gonna buy I'm buying
crypto right now have you considered
that Matt Damon thinks fortune favors
the brave aka the dumb Matt Damon
son of a uh of a like activist teacher
actually legitimately like uh like a
pretty like back in the day at least
like old die in the wool Lefty [__]
Shilling cryptocurrency you can't you
know
Sports fortune favors the brave my
friend all right so one thing I want to
make clear before we engulf on this um
conversation
is that me and you pretty much have like
95 crossover
in terms of like
our goal for the welfare of the people
of our utopian society yeah I mean my my
my guiding hope
in social democracy is that you can take
the the both of best worlds of socialism
and capitalism and create a world where
the poorest are are cared for where
people can get free education where
people can get free housing or not free
but guaranteed housing where they get a
guaranteed education higher education
all this stuff so let's talk about this
now my first question is this
given that you know in a social
democracy we can regulate things like
taxes housing higher education sharing
jobs and all this kind of stuff what are
the problems in social democracy that we
need socialism to address what is it
socialism does that social democracy
doesn't do
so social democracy is still capitalist
um uh with with you know serious severe
Market regulations right
um some forms of viable social
democracies you can point to right now
is places like Norway an example I use
regularly
the issue is twofold one social
democracies don't address some of the
domestic problems because when there's
still capital accumulation of which
domestic problems domestic problems such
as labor issues homelessness like
there's no way to fully eradicate that
because the inherent class contradiction
between the owner class and the labor
class still exists that's an assumption
I don't know that that's true that
there's just gonna be there's not gonna
be homelessness in socialism but they're
willing social democracy well the idea
is that
um
completely
abolishing the profit motive in certain
Commodities like housing for example
will address that problem because then
you're making housing specifically for
need rather than so you can make money
off of existing units right but it will
so it right there be government housing
like for example like I think that
exists in Sweden yeah where if you're
homeless is what yeah it exists
everywhere so that's what I'm saying
there's not a profit motive there's
there's a
humanitarian effort to um
to house the the people that need homes
and he was eating and now you know so so
I I don't know what you mean that
there's homelessness won't exist in
socialism but she's eating all your
tissues oh nasty oh yeah she's eating
all your tissues sorry as it grows
question girl yeah shame on you yeah she
she being a nasty girl today or used to
do that she's being a real freak
um sorry what's the homelessness in
Sweden that's just as a I mean oh before
we look at those numbers something to
consider something to remember always is
that
um homelessness is tracked very
differently in different countries okay
so like those numbers will always be
um those numbers can be uh very
different like you could think that oh
it's so much worse like like rape
statistics in Sweden if you look at that
I think gonna test this too you'd be
like what the [__] it's crazy out there
people are raping like crazy and it's
because they have a different
methodology for tracking rape like each
individual Act of sexual assault this
track is looking uh like uh is written
up as like one individual the actual
number then isn't that important but we
acknowledge that in a social democracy
that's run ideally
the homeless and whoever else needs a
home for whatever reason would be
provided one so I don't understand what
socialism does better in that case
um at the end of the day these countries
the social democracy we were talking
about still have a lot of wealthy
individuals a lot of people who are
making money off of Finance capital and
capitalism in general and their
interests are always going to be to
further erode the welfare state as best
as they possibly can in an effort to
claw back all of those areas that they
could so you'll technically putting that
on them but that's not if you have a
strong social democracy that wouldn't be
possible well my question to you would
be if everybody's provided for in the
society adequately and and
uh fairly then what why do you care how
much money somebody has
um because well first of all I don't but
the real reason is not necessarily money
but more so how people make their money
and how people make their money being
through capital accumulation is always
going to uh work to erode this nation
the the Social Democratic state that
you're mentioning and the example I will
use is Europe because like if you look
at European Social Democratic reforms
throughout uh history things that a lot
of people take for granted even the NHS
in the UK for example is not immediately
uh privatized obviously but uh it is
crippled under conservative
administrations deliberately
specifically so that they can inevitably
privatize certain aspects of it it's
kind of like how uh the same neoliberal
reforms under the Reagan Era wanted to
openly starve the Beast the American
government which is why Americans no
longer have any sort of confidence in
the government to do any kind of social
uh amenities any kind of offerings right
like you understand you and I we we both
are in the highest tax bracket we live
in Los Angeles California yeah we pay a
[__] ton of taxes we pay like European
taxes right yeah
um and the reality is we both recognize
that those taxes don't necessarily go to
the places that we would love for it
love for them to be spent on definitely
roads schools libraries social democracy
that like my utopian social democracy
well there's all that money in this you
know situation it does go to those
places because they because America is
still a capitalist Nation just like all
of these other countries are yeah and in
a capitalist Nation you are always going
to have the influence of capital let me
ask you this then okay in a socialist
Nation on the other flip of the coin
wouldn't you also also have this a
similar movement of people a party of
people wanting to move towards
capitalism
there will there will probably there
will always be yes people what's the
difference counter-revolutionary
um well not just that I mean there's a
move because capitalism
um
social democracy there's a certain level
of
individualism that you don't have with
with uh socialism but perhaps I would
say and so
and so I would ask you what's the
difference you're saying that social
democracy nations are gonna the rich
people are always going to be trying to
erode the system
that's an assumption by the way
um well it's not an assumption
necessarily is it's not it's not
descriptive in comparison to like I mean
it's descriptive if you look at
um how it has uh played itself out in
Europe where we and you're right I agree
I agree that's what they'll be doing so
I'm not going to argue even America
America had a lot of Social Democratic
principles in the New Deal I'm not even
going to argue that but I do think that
in a socialist country like I said
there's going to be a sizable amount of
people moving towards capitalism so
what's the difference I don't know if
it'll be as sizable and there also
always has to be a state mechanism of
control which exists in neoliberal
capitalism as well and um
this is actually an area where I very
much uh uh diverge from the from other
socialists I would say or even more
Orthodox marxists that I believe the
neoliberal mechanisms of control
um specifically
uh it's just
how do I describe it free market uh
markets are better than okay than the
government at dealing with everything
okay
um
so
I I think that there is uh two different
as as reductive as possible there's two
different types of control control is
always going to happen this is what the
state is there to do right uh under
liberal capitalist democracies in the
west you have a neoliberal mechanism of
control that doubles the masses through
Commodities gives you the false uh
notion of choice you feel like you have
32 different brands of Oreos even though
they're like owned by three companies
that price fix right and they basically
control all matter of Commodities and
those markets are completely captured
but there's this idea that there are uh
you know this endless boundless amount
of of choices that you can choose from
on the other side the more authoritarian
mechanisms of control which have existed
what's your opinion
I like the neoliberal one I think that
uh even in a socialist State uh you
should still very much give the people
uh the the false notion of choice and
make it feel like they have a say in the
process while doing the bidding of I
mean it's a pretty cynical world view
but I think that you know that's what
states are supposed to do let me ask you
this and that and we'll create a
structure where there are significantly
less uh people who are like I hate the
system right now I don't feel happy I
don't feel good in the system that I
exist under so I should uh you know do
counter-revolutionary capitalist reforms
well and likewise I don't think there's
that many people in Sweden or Norway who
are saying no we need to move to a pure
socialist because everybody there is
provided for I don't think there's a
large I I'm speaking at it no you're
you're absolutely right you're actually
100 correct so like some Orthodox
marxists actually hate the welfare state
for this reason because the welfare
state is a continuation of capitalism by
offering social offering certain
amenities
thrived and uh and and has created a
structure where like the inherent
contradictions that exist under
capitalism that I think everyone would
agree with including yourself uh those
inherent contradictions become a little
bit more muddied and they never end up
getting to a point where uh they they
converge and and uh capitalism erodes
into some socialist formation let me be
I guess more specific if you're in a
socialist
country
is there one party or multiple parties
um it depends I mean because one party's
scary right can we agree on that one is
not a good system I think you and I
would agree that we
no no I'm just asking you I don't care
about the United States I'm asking you
about socialism I I think that there are
different forms of governance and the
United States is not that different I
don't care about the United States I
want to know I just want to talk about a
socialist I think that no matter what
happens the state does what the state is
supposed to do you can either do it at
the behest of your citizens because you
genuinely earnestly believe that like
that is the best possible way of
developing a society or you do it at the
behest of capital owners and and
capitalism but you're saying you don't
think it matters if there's one party or
I don't think it matters as far as
um I care about direct democracy direct
Democratic participation in local uh in
in one party systems with Socialism or
communism has pretty much always been
a catastrophe yeah a human humanitarian
disaster no no I agree with that there's
just so much risk in having one party I
I agree with that I think that a
multi-party system is obviously going to
be better my point is that it doesn't
even matter if you have a parliament it
doesn't even matter if you have a
multi-party system the changes that are
being made in one direction or the other
are oftentimes incredibly marginal
um and and less and the differences are
not born out of like uh you know the
party disagreements differences are born
out of like genuine material conflict
like even including like the Civil War
it's never like the kindness of people's
uh or like one party of individuals
being like we are kind we want to do
good things and the other side is bad
and they want to do bad things so what I
want to say was this then but if you're
in a socialist
country with multiple parties and one of
the parties is a capitalist party which
would surely exist yeah what would you
do if that party started gaining
momentum and it was clearly like people
wanted that route they wanted that route
yeah what do you do I think um I would
do what America has done not to the same
which is right not to the same degree as
like uh you know McCarthy's trials or
anything like that
um but I would offer additional
amenities to ensure that people are
comfortable and happy because I feel
like anything what do you do if they're
like nah [__] that we're doing
capitalism well if everything is if
everything is given to you yeah at that
point if every single thing is given to
you if all of your problems are solved
which I think we can both agree uh is is
not under capitalism it has not happened
no
um if all of those problems have been
solved then there is no need for
conflict of that regard but they're
saying no we want ultimate because
they're like yo this is a free country
right well we want to do capitalism
we think the market should regulate the
prices and [__] we don't think the
workplace should be um socialized okay
that's a great that's a great question
and what about you have to ask why
though at that point because well people
never can be explained by why anyway you
know what I mean some people are gonna
be dumb you're right it's like you don't
it's just gonna exist you know it is
yeah and so and so if the will of the
people is to go back to do more of a
social democracy is that something that
a socialist country should move towards
or should there be resistance in the
government to keep socialism I think the
resistance should be akin to how
capitalist governments have resisted
historically any kind of socialist
movement not to that same degree of
violence but I think that yes
um the the solution to that would always
be education and offering more
re-education
re-education certainly yeah
I know that that's like a traditional
camps no no not like that
um I know there's a trigger word because
everyone goes oh re-education what do
you mean like immediately people think
like are you telling me about that are
you talking about like resident schools
are you talking about uh yeah 100 they
do they do it they did it in xinjiang
which is pretty good right no I don't
agree with that yeah I don't think it
was good and this is uh something I have
openly criticized as well like the
that's not good
the massive surveillance apparatus they
built in xinjiang is not good so what
would be even about a socialist
re-education camp for capitalists it
wouldn't necessarily I don't think it'd
be camps I mean it depends on it depends
on crime right like are people
committing crimes at the behest of this
because if there's a socialist State and
someone is doing like white Terror let's
say or someone is doing South Korean
style uh you know purges of Communists
which have always which has happened
historically in every country that
America is aligned with because they
were anti-communist where they've
launched you know military dictatorships
whether we recognize it or not those
things have happened right so in a
situation like that
um I think if there's any kind of like
terrorism happening sure yeah if there's
violence then yes I do think that uh
there should be an enforcement mechanism
and in that enforcement mechanism I
think like Rehabilitation which would
include re-education as well would
probably be a lot better than like uh
you know
a prison structure where they have
slavery like in the United States of
America I'm still a little bit confused
about the ideal mechanism of a socialist
country whereas
there where people still have individual
freedoms to like form to assemble and
can also be like yeah I'm a capitalist
so what and we're trying to grow our
movement I don't understand the
organization of the Socialist free
country because it seems to me to have a
socialist country
uh that there needs to be some amount of
dampening of you know uh rights
well because for what yes and no because
my point is always the same uh it's that
this is a constant this is consistent
what you're describing is consistent
with the American formation it's
consistent with capitalism it's just a
reality that will always exist violence
and who gets to do violence is an
inherent part of politics because
politics is uh at the end of the day a
distribution of resources and a
distribution of violence who gets to
have what resources and who doesn't have
the resources as a consequence of that
and if they do something to get those
resources what the state will be able to
do the state has a monopoly on violence
across the board no matter what happens
right
I'm not an anarchist a lot of anarchists
will get mad at me for saying this but
the state should have some level of of a
violent mechanism because well no matter
what happens and there's different forms
of violence as well the structural
violence poverty or direct violence in
the in uh in the form of of uh military
uh boots on the ground military Warfare
imperialism police violence police
brutality these are all different forms
of violence there will be some exertion
of force required to maintain a
socialist group not just a social
country any country sure any country yes
I agree until
we uh reach a point of of I guess uh
until we reach a point of production uh
and our productive output has gotten to
a point where it's so streamlined and
and so organized that there is no need
for a state but I don't know if we will
ever be able to get there uh where the
state Withers away and we have a
classless borderless moneyless society
the problem yeah I mean if it is
world war three or something
um let me ask you I guess another angle
here
um ex worker exploitation seems to be at
the heart of socialism and
so I want to ask you this question if an
employee is fairly compensated and by
fairly I mean
that
factors like work
um uh compensation you know they're
being paid well beyond the means of
living they can afford a comfortable
housing food pleasure vacation savings
all the things people would want to do
with money if they're provided and all
those ways that are we see as important
is that still exploitation
um in the marxian sense yes in the
capital of sense no capitalism well
social so Mark when you say Marxism
you're talking about socialism yes yes
yes so uh in the in the Marxist
perspective under you know marxian
economics Marxist theory uh exploitation
is not a good or bad thing uh it is just
a thing that happens okay
um and it goes back to something I've
described many many times over which is
that the there are two classes
um
there is the labor class the wage
laborers the proletariat and the the
Bourgeois class the capital loaning
class right and these two classes have
two inherently contradictory interests
you work jobs when you had a boss and
someone was paying you and you have been
a boss so you have gone through both of
these stages so as someone who worked in
a job as a wage laborer as a W-2
employer 1099 contractor you wanted to
work the least amount of hours for the
most amount of pay that's understandable
that's like perfectly reasonable right
like you want more money and you want to
work less hours you want to have more
freedom
your boss on the other hand wants you to
work the most amount of hours for the
least amount of pay like that they can
get away with yeah so
um this inherent contradiction is at the
heart of capitalism and is how
Commodities are produced under a
capitalist mode of production
now when you have this when you have
this imbalance those who do have Capital
end up always being able to pay you
much less than your actual output that
is what's happening now my question is
in a situation as I outlined where the
employees are fairly provided for which
I outlined before is that when I say
exploitation I mean like
I think that also has a vernacular like
when the ruling class is
um committing some kind of harm or
Injustice on their workers
um no it it's it's beyond that you could
be paying your employees fairly and
still engage in the active exploitation
so then because I don't want to get top
on that because you're saying
exploitation is neutral by itself
exploitation in the marxian sense is not
good or bad it's just descriptive a lot
of what Marx has talked about but so
what does he mean then the scripted
descriptive what does he mean then when
he goes the exploitation of workers
clearly he wants to end the exploitation
of course so is it still exploitation of
workers if they're fairly provided for
yes because because the the fairness in
this regard is not met on the metrics of
like living standards but instead on the
metrics of what their output is so when
and and this gets into the labor theory
of value excuse right goddamn the labor
theory of value which is which is
different than marginal utility which is
what we use currently when we ascribe
when we just when we say this is this
much like something is disvaluable Right
ice cream is four dollars
um but if it's really hot out maybe ice
cream is five dollars because well
there's a little bit of scarcity on uh
on on the supply but the demand has gone
up so now ice cream is more expensive
whereas from a marxian perspective the
value of that ice cream is uh is is
is stable it's just what kind of Labor
went into the production of it what were
the uh what were the the resources used
to make that ice cream what kind of like
what uh kind of capital was put into the
Ice Cream Factory and then also the the
the the moving part in that situation
would be the labor of it if the employee
is
extremely satisfied yeah and they feel
well provided for it
I mean in a sense it's like who are you
to tell him he's being exploited
well you're you're again
but you know what I mean yeah no I
understand it's
what I would say in that situation is
this right
um relying on the magnanimous nature of
your boss yeah and hoping that like your
boss doesn't uh succumb to Greed and and
choose to change certain things about
your workplace conditions can be great
and there are people like yourself out
there who are as far as I understand
pretty good bosses right but that that
is never going to be the that's never
going to be the constant that's never
going to be the case but in social
democracy you set up the bumpers you set
up the systems where yeah they they have
to do that well that's the bare minimum
they have to do well and then we go back
to the erosion of the the amenities I
don't feel like that's a strong enough
argument to say socialism is better no
as long as there is as long as there is
a some kind of of uh capitalist
compensation in any sort of sector they
will always choose to monopolize this is
what most companies like this is what
every company does when they become a
company a corporation their their job is
to their goal is to inevitably become a
monopoly you can do that by renting so
what if you know so what
if there's they still have to follow the
rules
well no when you are when you are
becoming a monopoly yeah you are either
engaging in horizontal integration and
expansion or vertical integration and
expansion mergers Acquisitions
um and and you know what Amazon has done
for example in in e-commerce is a great
example of this and when you get to that
point uh especially under a capitalist
state that still has Market reforms you
end up uh using the the additional
Capital that you've accumulated in the
form of profits from your workers to
Lobby the government and erode the
safety nets but you're talking like it's
a guaranteed and again I'm gonna
guarantee every single one and I and
it's been a guarantee by the same metric
that any socialist country devolves into
into disaster I mean it's not fair to
put it that out there like it's just
given because on the on the other flip
coin you can say uh you know this like I
mentioned socialism there's going to be
people moving towards capitalism so
socialism it's too hypothetical
however historically most of them at
least have not eroded or been destroyed
due to like people who are just like I
want to be capitalists usually those
people are being uh goaded or supported
facilitated by a much more powerful
Nation
um that uh is is using the the uh
inherent greed to their advantage to uh
cause divisions but the real material
issues in socialist nation states
historical socialism uh real socialism
in the real world that has happened has
always been due to mishaps uh you know
famine uh or or the government
exercising too much authoritarian yeah
you can stay the same these sorts of
things these sorts of things uh are are
the real reasons as to why socialization
states have failed not necessarily their
their economic motor production
switching over to a more labor focused
uh economy and and then also
um there there are so many different
types of uh socialist developments
like a socialist mode of production that
um there is no like one
absolute perfect one and I'd be a liar
if I told you I know which one it is you
know what I mean so go back to the the
original question let's just ignore this
um theory that in social democracy and
I'll say this you know obviously we have
Anti-Trust laws that are not good that
are not been effective in the least bit
yeah that's something you can regulate
no but I would ask you why well because
our our government is super corrupt why
is the government corrupt because people
aren't are inherently flawed
you think the governments grow up
because people are inherently flawed
corruption in that sense I disagree with
you there some people not all people
that's another thing I said people are
inherently greedy and people lost their
mind some people are but really I want
to talk about that at better length but
go ahead that's actually a great take as
well we can cover that as well yeah I
always butchered this quote but I forget
who it was it might have been Mark
Fisher might have been someone else but
um assuming that greed is inherent in
human nature under a capitalist
organization of the economy is like
assuming The Black Lung is inherent I'm
not human nature if you work at a
[__] Coal Mine see that's that's not
a good analogy because no you're in my
opinion breed is a part of it
self-interest is a part of it not greed
necessarily but self-interest is a part
of human existence why we have uh built
societies how we've done it however as a
survival is a biological survival
exactly however if we didn't have
self-interest we would never we we
wouldn't survive as a species I don't
disagree with you yeah you're absolutely
correct my argument always and many
Marx's arguments actually have always
been around individuals them and
self-interest and how socialism as a
matter of fact creates more
opportunities for individual liberties
for the person uh it's only been sold
and told to people as though it is uh
you know this this gray brutalist
architecture city blocks you don't you
have to you know do your government
mandated coal mining job or whatever the
[__] but
um the the ultimate goal has always been
to open up more individual liberties
I'll give you an example of
socialization that you and I both agree
with right Health Care nationalized
Health Care or socialized medicine in
general gives you more Liberties as a
person that you can actually leave your
job that would happen in social
democracy as well yes
however
like I've said there has to be the the
the counter measures in a social
democracy
um are are like the the capitalist
forces are significantly more powerful
because ultimately the state is still
operating as a capitalist state that is
still the norm so I think we're having
like a a kind of just like a disc or not
a disconnect but maybe had an impasse on
that idea but what I'll say I want to
give you a specific example because this
this is interesting to me
um let's just take this workplace as an
example because we're all familiar with
it
so I started my career
10 plus years ago and I was successful
by myself with zero employees yes I made
a lot of money I was I did well for
myself and then you know five years ago
into my career I made a punk I made the
podcast which obviously you all are
watching now
so
so let's say we go back to five years
ago when I hired Dan as a freelance you
started as like a consultant
yeah or a freelancer yeah and obviously
you moved to full time and I'll get to
that yeah so he he started as like a
freelance consultant so what would be a
fair way of compensating him for that
in your situation
um
it's it's uh like what is the most like
socialist way of doing it is that what
you're asking well yeah because that's
what I'm talking about right um it would
be it would be profit sharing uh well
ideas so so this is this is interesting
hold on this is interesting you're right
because this is actually the most
difficult aspect in my opinion of of
like trying to create the most ethical
way of existing under a capitalist
organization of the economy while you
are also productive uh and and you're
you're doing like an owned and operated
Media Company where you are the product
so I hired Dan as a consultant yeah just
to help us out to get things uh and I
have hired people as well so then so
then we're PR I'm profit sharing with
him how much profit am I sharing so the
way I do it and I think this is this
will be uh I mean this is this is
instructive for many others as well the
way I do it like the most ethical way to
do it is basically try to make an
assessment
um sure there's Market considerations on
the one hand like what the normal wage
would look like but that is like the the
minimum you know what I mean that is
like the minimum that is the the worst
possible amount to pay someone in in the
form of wages in my opinion Okay so
you have the market considerations on
the one side
um which I don't necessarily care too
much about
um on the other side you have your
productive output right let's say you
were making ten dollars before Dan came
on and now that Dan came on they're
making that wouldn't be measurable no no
I know I know I completely agree with
you yeah I know
um which is why I'm saying it's it's a
tricky situation it's almost impossible
yeah yeah well technically the other
side is also very cruel but there's like
normal because in social democracy
people are fairly compensated it's not
cruel in my opinion
no there's I I don't think I I think we
we people can be more or less
fairly compensated but like generally
speaking they'd be more fairly
compensated than what we would see today
yes in comparison to the United States
of America which technically would be a
mixed market or social democracy social
democracies in other countries there is
better compensation so here's the
unintended consequence of that due to
you know regulation government
regulations if I'm if I'm just hiring
Dan to come in and help me with cameras
and stuff and I have to cut him in on
profit share people are not going to
hire as many people they're going to
think a lot more before they bring more
people on well can I can I just chime in
real quick just to clarify this point
are you still talking about the the
period of time where I was working as a
contractor yes I haven't gone to the
full time yet well we're going to move
to that right I will just say that at
the time I was essentially operating as
my own business as well because you
weren't my only client at this right
okay I I did that professionally for a
lot of people and you were one of many
people that I would come and do shows
with until you offered me a full-time
thing so just because we're using the
specific example I just wanted to
clarify that because I think that
matters and what the dynamic was when we
were initially working together I don't
think that matters in such that I'm more
focused just on the profit sharing the
reason why I was bringing up the the
implications on to a business and
business owner of that okay but the
reason why I was bringing up the revenue
is because let's say you were making 10
you're making ten dollars Dan comes on
now you're making 15 yeah right Dan has
brought in five extra dollars of revenue
for you and I think that uh the the best
possible way
to to engage with that would be to cut
Dan in on uh like offer Dan living wages
plus uh whatever
uh whatever Dan has brought in in the
form of Revenue this is a big problem
and and that moves that moves into
Direction like you make and then later
down the line you make a hundred uh
thousand dollars and and moves with now
yeah
here's where this seems more like it's a
nice Theory but like in application it
makes no sense who decides how much
value he's brought how could you
possibly decide that if my show is
growing Dan joins and let's say yeah I
now I'm making 15 but the show was
organically growing how how can I how
can I attribute all five of that to Dan
you're absolutely
50 with him this is this is something
that I do not have an answer for either
which is why it doesn't like I said
which is why like I said you make do
with uh you you try to do your very best
can I can I be this seems like a big
problem to say you don't have a solution
for if you're advocating for a socialist
society I I agree which is why I always
seem like it's ready well can I just
chime in on this this isn't theoretical
there are there are lots of companies
that do do profit sharing I do this I
know but it's not like but like let's
say this and they have various methods
of how they do it the way I there are
ways to do it that makes sense I do that
the way that socialism does it in the
purest sense is like Dan joined 10 to 15
Dan gets half of the 15. so that's his
that's his even this is if we're talking
piercings if we're talking if we're
talking pure Theory yeah I would rather
have an imperfect structure that still
absolutely offers it but it doesn't work
well if you don't know how people get
paid how does it even work the
capitalist structure also is imperfect
in the exact same world functioning at
least yes I know but the the idea that
like the other structure would not
function is not correct especially when
we're telling you that even under a
capitalist organization economy there's
plenty of different ways of doing it one
of the most successful ones that I also
have have is a Cooperative right I have
a Cooperative uh collectively organized
podcast for example where we just split
it five ways regardless obviously my
output in that situation given that I am
uh the the uh like the host with the
largest audience would significantly
outweigh my producers for example who uh
could be paid uh with a very fair very
fat Market uh wage right Market wage
plus uh Market wage times three is what
I could pay him and it would still be
significantly less than what he gets
paid now yeah because we're we're
cutting him in uh five ways we're
splitting everything five ways yeah and
and that is a perfectly viable way to do
it because I think that's very generous
but I don't think you should be forced
to do that I think that I think you
should be forced to pay him what we've
determined as a minimum wage where he
can live in where he lives in a in a
comfortable state
generous it goes beyond wages as well
there's also another aspect of this that
uh many people fail to consider which is
decision making so uh there's also the
structure of decision making the the
structure of autonomy when we are
setting up the time for when we are
going to shoot the podcast like everyone
has to be on board with it it has to
work around every single person's
schedule these are all uh scheduling
conflicts exist usually but it's like
um in in good faith every single person
is like giving their most uh giving
their all and It ultimately I think
creates a pretty pretty solid product
let me ask you
so do you acknowledge that in this
socialist uh fear theoretical country
where I where I go from 10 to 15 and I
give Dan 15. hypothetic for any worker
joining that I as a business owner I
would be less likely to be hiring people
certainly and that's not good is it no I
don't agree with that I don't think
that's a necessarily a bad thing at all
because like I I don't know because like
I've gone through a lot of people that
did not work out um
and they were they they were hired on
like uh let's say
um
exploratory so so is it at will
employment in this situation in this
structure you can you can still of
course like you can still uh have issues
with uh with an employee and fire them
there's it's ironic because like Japan
for example is like a most capitalist
country on the planet and yet uh in
Japan they have this like very unique
culture where getting into a place of
business is very difficult but once you
actually have made it into the
corporation they don't fire you they
can't fire you they never fire you what
they do is they they ostracize you and
and make you into a social Pariah within
the company right and and try to get you
to quit is it because they're trying to
avoid paying some kind of severance or
is it just no it's like it's both
cultural and I if I'm not mistaken it
could literally legal implications as
well but it but it works right okay it
technically works but I'm saying why is
it
hey why is it not a good thing so as a
business owner I think the fact that I
was not super hesitant to hire lots of
people find the crew that works I work
local a lot of people it did not who
were not compatible so I was able to
burn through enough people to find a
team that that worked right so if if I
was so hesitant to hire people because I
have to profit share with them I would
do like a way more strenuous interview
process but it seems way longer you're
making an argument for why it's stronger
like I don't deal with though at all you
lucked out with Dan I don't think that's
an argument because first of all it's
good that people can go try a bunch of
jobs before they try find one that works
and as an employer it's good to be able
to try a bunch of people do you find the
right fit for employees if I had to go
through these strenuous process to find
each one of them this podcast may very
well likely not exist as it does today
might not exist as at all I I disagree
with you on that for sure I think that I
think that it's better to have a
strenuous process of of ensuring that
you have for life even for like the most
entry-level job
um yeah I think that it's but that
doesn't know it doesn't that result in
people not getting work so yes it will
so there's but then but then we're
talking about like an entirely separate
way of of organizing the economy why is
it better why is it better that I have
to go through like
we're talking about hypotheticals yeah
in this situation yeah so it can like I
can just hypothesize that you found Dan
not even no no we're not talking well
we're talking hypothetically but we're
talking you found Dan so you clearly but
we went through a lot of people before
we found that yeah well you could have
arrived at Dan as well is what I'm
saying it would have taken a lot
stronger and the business might not have
survived okay
so there was a point where the podcast
almost got wrapped up yeah so why is it
better in theory to have that extraneous
of a hiring process than being able to
kind of just people try things out
um it's only this is only one aspect of
it but what you're talking about like
the extraneous hiring process also would
exist under a social democracy as well
it should exist in some form under
social democracy as well like why some
level of protection from from being
fired but so in social democracy you're
not rev sharing so there's like this big
thing that you're like I'm a business
owner I've created this business for my
own sweat and Blood and Tears over the
last 10 years and I'm making a lot of
money I gotta hire this guy who I don't
know anything about and I gotta cut him
in on my profits that doesn't exist in
social democracy
so the risk to me as the business owner
is way way way but it's much smaller to
a much smaller degree because it it's
supposed to exist through unions and
once again it's not just Revenue share
but everyone always everyone always
focuses on that aspect of it but rev
sharing comes in the form of benefits
rev sharing comes in the form of like
how much we invest in r d for example or
what kind of r d initiatives we invest
in all of these decisions are made by a
board well that's all regulatory
responsibility to the shareholders that
is not regulated under social democracy
this this is the this is the major point
I mean by register then because you see
in our example like in Germany they have
the a Trade union representative uh that
that sits on the board of Executives but
that's only one that's only one aspect
of a uh a larger board that is still
representing the interests of of the
shareholders those who own the company
who never have seen the company they can
you know even globally own it right so
having one vote in that situation is not
as good in my opinion as having all of
the vote all of the Power making these
decision decisions as a collective
something that kind of is not legally
enforced here right in your structure
but you kind you abide by because you're
a nice guy many people are not going to
be like that many and I'm saying that we
shouldn't rely on the magnanimity
we're going back to this point because
we don't have to with the right well
even an example let me ask you the one I
mentioned it still yields terrible like
still is susceptible it's not a social
democracy Capital let me ask you that
yes it is Germany Germany arguably is
yes
America is a social democracy as well
the problem is like American social
democracy is a is a laughable uh example
so let's not use it then but it's going
back why is it better because I don't
think I ever got an answer
to have a strenuous hiring process
why is it better to have a shinies uh
you are when you engage in in commodity
production with another person I think
it's perfectly valid to ensure that this
person is not going to be like a scumbag
and cheat you [__] you over I think it's
it's good business practice even on a
capitalist sense to ensure that the
person that you're hiring is not like
like some [__] well right because
that's just um yeah that's just common
sense and the more you do acknowledge
that so you do acknowledge the heads and
hesitancy to hire people I do I do I
don't know what okay I don't think it's
about I guess a bit of it because again
because and as companies grow you have
different people in different units that
also are you know uh engaging in hiring
like it's just that workers now have
more of a say in which direction the
company should go and that's a good
thing it's not bad for me for like a
week and on my business I spent five
years building I don't want to give him
a decision on where the company goes
I think that why should he have that
right you know what I mean I I'm not
saying the janitor comes in and
unilaterally makes decisions that's not
how that works but I'm curious how it
does work so it's a it's a it's
communication the other person is a
human being as well if you have a major
disagreement then you look for someone
else to work in that position this is
how it works okay
you don't have the you don't have the
the the fear of like subsistence living
at the other end of that bargain whereas
like you have better amenities better
protections and and therefore you're
more comfortable with good living
conditions because
the idea is what I'm already saying that
I don't think that makes socialism
unique because we can provide good
living conditions and benefits can but
we haven't now that by the way one
aspect of social democracy that we've
talked about is the domestic one we have
yet to even uncover the other much worse
side of social democracies which is uh
resource extraction in the third world
and imperialism uh and and that is a
necessity under global capitalism and
that is the reason why we have the Haves
and the have-nots on the domestic level
you believe that there is a regulatory
agency that can make things more
conversation about the third world stuff
because I'm not super familiar with it
perfectly fine but like I can but you
understand that like that's a part of
everything well so exploiting in the
truest sense of the word is definitely
what's been happening even even on a
capitalist understanding that's like
hyper exploitation clearly I think that
all humans on this Earth deserve um
rights and comfort and yeah and right
yeah you know what I mean it is funny
one thing I will mention in the domestic
you know going back to the labor force
thing is like we're so susceptible and
and so programmed under capitalist Dogma
that we refuse to see a world outside of
it and we're so captured in that uh in
that world view that uh oftentimes the
the number one counter against a
socialist governance or democracy in the
workplace or anything like that is
always like what do you want the [__]
janitor just came in yesterday to make
these decisions like no one said he's
the CEO you want to understand how it
works because you keep saying for real
share
okay here is an example when I first
started the podcast I was originally
undercast it was [__] terrible we
quit we started our own podcast me and
will we need a producer because we don't
have that skill set we need someone to
change the cameras and maybe do a little
bit of uh you know someone to post the
videos do the captions titling
thumbnailing right so
in that situation we looked for someone
we found someone and we were splitting
it three ways we were splitting the
revenue three ways anything that we made
right and even before that I was also
giving March money as well to make sure
that he like at least had a [__] you
know had had a revenue opportunity even
when we weren't generating a lot of
Revenue okay right so what did I do
after that the podcast grew fear and now
has five cast members we brought in
Austin show my good friend and cutie
Cinderella and when that happened us
three we got together and we had a
conversation okay do we need more hosts
do we think that this will be beneficial
right right do we think that we will end
up making you know more Revenue
generating more Revenue in the long run
right will we have people with unique uh
creative ideas like I care more about
the creative output than anything else
than Revenue I haven't even touched the
[__] Revenue that I've generated from
the podcast
um and we got together and we had a
conversation and I think that
that is a significantly more Equitable
and just and better way of doing
business than me hiring March me giving
Will some money originally like a fat
salary or maybe cutting in on the Rev
share for him and then giving March like
a super high [__] wage right way
higher than like the average producer
and then and then making these decisions
single-handedly let me add another
aspect to your example let's say you
need to hire a cleaner to come clean the
office
she works for the podcast she comes she
cleans the office she works full time
how do you pay her
um the the cleaner side of this is not
like I mean I don't have office like
that but the janitorial services
theoretically in a theoretical situation
where we have someone full-time that
needs to do it yeah we would we would
also get together as a unit okay the
existing company would get together and
decide what level just like hiring the
two other hosts we decide what level of
Revenue Cuts we are going to take from
our five percent to give you're making
her the other part it's not really that
different than a salary and and once
they get that job and there are many
different ways of doing this but once
they get that job and let's say they
worked for two years three years then
they have a say in the revenue sharing
structure and the power sharing
structure as well because it doesn't
have to happen like instantaneously a
lot of people forget that my problem is
that in the Socialist uh economy this is
being regulated by the government people
can get together now and decide to do
whatever the [__] they want in their
company and that's great you know but in
the socialistic economy there's rules
that says you need to pay her x amount
of rev share what you're saying is not
true okay you want to know why yes
because you want a social democracy
which kind of exists and Market
regulation exists under capitalist
formations and plenty of capital owners
hate that as a matter of fact I would
say universally Capital owners hate any
kind of Market regulation which is why
they choose to erode it as best as they
possibly can or they use it to their
advantage to create an artificial
barrier of entry into certain sectors
I'm saying in a socialist economy
there's going to be laws it's just like
there are laws in a capitalist economy
socialism how how
I'm saying the government is telling you
how much you need to pay
the janitor that's not how that would
work then how would it work because it
would be it would be isn't that how how
is that functionally different than a
minimum wage that's my point that's my
point yeah so well I think but socialism
is much more radical we're talking about
social it doesn't have to be yeah
moving America to a purely socialistic
Society instead of my thing is I think
social democracy is better than
socialism and you guys are explaining
something to that to me sounds a lot
like something that we can already do
without this huge undertaking of
changing our economy from a capitalist
to social democracy one to a socialism
one you're talking about a minimum wage
we already do that and we can already do
better of that with that via regulations
but why the reason why we haven't been
able to is because like I will I think
the best way to explain it is this way
okay
you like capitalism with socialist
characteristics I like socialism with
capitalist character yo you just said
that so we're both social so that
doesn't mean that I'm no friend I still
believe that the government good
difference now you said you like social
media is no I I said I like socialism
yeah with capitalist characteristics
meaning that the governing the the the
governing uh economy like the entire
economy still revolves around a
socialist mode of production where the
owners uh the workers are the owners
they own the means of production they
have the they have a say in their
benefits they have a saying
though well you there will still
obviously be protections against like
unjust firings and whatnot and there
should be certainly there are no and
there are now as well America is a great
example in California there are really
America is a great example however of
like how there aren't which how it
shouldn't be and it shouldn't be that
way exactly and but the reason why it's
not that way is because we have
capitalism with like laughable socialist
characters it's very interesting that
you're saying you want socialism with
capital capitalist character capitalist
characteristics in the sense that not
the it doesn't touch the means of
production or the the mode of production
but but offers uh and offers an
abundance of resources and offers the
the idea that you have freedom one of
the major problems with former
historic socialist projects have always
been commodity production being
streamlined on necessity and not
necessarily silly things like lighter
production industries that revolve
around making uh I don't know chocolate
and and coffee coffee was a major
problem in in in uh East Germany so like
things of that nature that people need
um I think those are things that we need
to work on uh and and that capitalism I
think has done a much better job at
offering uh to people and that has a
very sedating uh influence on the masses
I don't think it's humorism I don't see
what's so great and humanizing about
hiring a janitor for point zero zero
zero zero one five percent of the
company
what do you I don't understand wait
that's not what I said you just you just
made that a certainly but we're saying
there's a minimum wage
there's a minimum equity share that that
janitor would need to get well are you
talking about in comparison to doing
we're talking about minimum wage
right well but comparing it to
uh a model where employees are cut in on
the profit is what you're saying
comparing that uh what we have now to
that yeah okay so I mean I would just
point out that well so first of all you
would have talked about it a lot earlier
about like well what companies do that
there's
a lot of examples of bigger firms that
do do this kind of thing okay um a great
one is Southwest Airlines did you know
that they have a massive employee profit
sharing model how does it work what's
the detail so it's a once a year payment
and they look at how they did the last
year and then a certain percentage of
the profits they distribute as bonuses
to all of the employees and it's fairly
significant dude that's great but in a
socialist country how that's it that's
all you want
because that's easy I can do I can you
know what I mean like like what are you
asking for when you're asking for
socialism just a bonus fun based on just
based on profit because that's easy uh
no not necessarily but I I mean listen I
wasn't trying to make any assertion
about that I was just trying to give you
an example of you were asking earlier
like what companies do that I think
here's a big one that does it I think
that's awesome and I'd even be in favor
of regulating that and saying yo you
need to put aside like five percent or
ten percent or whatever I don't care of
your profits to distribute even amongst
your employees is that socialism no
that's all it takes that would be some
aspect of socialization especially if
it's like earned by the workers that
have some level of uh of collective
bargaining it just seems so bureaucratic
I don't understand the workplace
bureaucracy still is very much the
foundation of an a Bourgeois State as
well it's just like that but like we we
don't think I'm talking like this is
bureaucratic bureaucracy on bureaucracy
on bureaucracy no I don't understand
your workplace I'll tell you that's not
good enough then what is I don't
understand uh there is I think uh it's
called People's Republic of Walmart it's
a really good book
um and and so like the title there was a
genuine problem in the USSR with how to
deal with uh crops and Agriculture and
Central planning unfortunately had
limitations at the time because we did
not have the computational power one of
the ironically uh uh it like Steps in in
the right direction was actually coming
from Chile
which then got their own 911 50 years
ago but we won't get into that because
you know socialism bad
um
but uh there was there wasn't enough
computational power and uh to to
implement centralized planning at that
time effectively and it led to plenty of
issues right so
ironically nowadays we are we we have
centralized planning
inside of Walmart inside of Amazon and
uh the these companies are generating a
ton of Revenue that they could cut their
workers into maybe they would be much
smaller maybe they could be maybe they
would be much smaller than minimum that
would make it socialist that's what I'm
curious about I don't I don't think
there's like a exact uh dollar value
rather than because you're looking for
an exact dollar value rather than I'm
talking about an entirely different way
of of thinking like there's the law
there's a law in a socialist country
that says You must do I'll give you I'll
give you one example I'll give you a
good example from your life right
right now
you've cam
all right cam does wonderful Goose gaps
and and Photoshop splaps we love cam
thank you and let's give it up let's
give everything real quick yeah I love
you guys I love you guys
so
technically if you were interested in
maximizing your Revenue
what you could have done instead of
hiring cam was Outsource it to Fiverr or
I don't know get like uh you know some
some Filipino graphic design company if
you were one of those like Tick Tock
guys out there who's like you know I
fired my entire workplace in like
[__] hired everyone in Pakistan for
you know five cents an hour it's [__]
sick like you could be one of those guys
and do that but the reason why you
didn't do that is because you feel as
though correctly that cam uh yields
better output hey hey no chewing she
almost I caught her no you do it no
Alfredo you got to enforce the law on
her no
Alfredo has no interest you have a
monopoly on violence sorry
it's okay I'll welcome uh a welcome uh
welcome to welcome bring yeah okay
please continue uh how old I am so
please don't do that and and there
should be restrictions on that uh
certainly like there should be
restrictions on being able to do that
um being able to just like completely
Outsource your your workplace
um those restrictions can come in a
capitalist country in the form of
tariffs which many do protectionist
trade uh or protocols exist globally
with the exception of the United States
of America which has some protectionist
policies but uh others that uh I mean
most protections policies still benefit
the interest of capital rather than the
working class there
um and and trade Partnerships have
created a structure where like labor has
been uh outsourced overseas our
manufacturing capabilities of being
completely outsourced these are very bad
things that exist exclusively due to uh
exclusive due to greed that you
understand
uh under under capitalism
that needs to constantly be put in check
but a government that is designed a
government that's full of rich people
that is interested in in their own uh in
their own wealth and wealth accumulation
that has stock options and trades like
Paul Pelosi and uh and and has you know
that gets jobs for their family members
and Goldman Sachs like Ted Cruz and and
many other examples is never going to
is never going to truly represent the
interests of the working class and is
always going to put the interests of
capital ahead of the interest of the
working class you will never be able to
have a real democracy that's the
difference between a Bourgeois democracy
and a proletarian democracy uh or a
dictatorship of the proletariat rather
than a dictatorship of the capital
owning class I just want to know how the
Socialist workplace works it seems so
nebulous when you talk about it why is
it I don't think it's nebulous at all I
have a living breathing working example
of it that I've given you
I know but like
foreign
there's got to be like a constitution
that says outlines or I don't know
whatever the [__] you want to write
right there's got to be something and it
says like our rule laws that says you
know this is the minimum that a person
should get from the company yes and we
should be married to the album it should
be married to the productive forces it
should be married to the output that
should be pegged let me talk about this
enough though I don't want to be pegged
to the performance and I think that that
is the best possible way I could work I
guess my problem on that is like how
could you possibly enforce that no not
even a force how could you possibly even
um
uh analyze that like how much how much
more uh how much more money are we
making because the janitor comes in
that's where we go to the Walmart
example
um that like we are already completely
aware of that we have you know it we
have actuaries we have uh CPAs that are
working in real time uh making
mathematical equations to figure out
exactly what not to pay people
technically
um and they could be in a total
reorganization of the economy with a
socialist document so it would work in
the opposite direction okay it's kind of
like this I I let's move to another talk
okay I don't want to bore people wealth
wealth was one aspect of this right like
we already have property taxes for
example in America but we never make
similar mathematical equations on
capital gains earnings that you make in
the stock market wealth accumulation
could work in the exact same way as
property taxes and yet we don't have any
mathematicians working on that that's a
good idea and and that's a great idea
right we'll probably do that in in a lot
of countries that aren't socialists
um well this is not just the distinction
between socialism because there is we
talked about that we talked a lot about
Theory but then we also have to talk
about like what is possible right at
least in the short term and that is the
reason why I always try to tell more uh
rugged more more rigid more um uh
passionate socialist that's where I'm
coming from to cooperate I know to
cooperate with people that are also
perceived as radicals in America like
there's a reason why Bernie Sanders who
has been a socialist entire life
basically is only implemented instituted
or advocated for Social Democratic
reforms in the United States of America
that's it that's the only there's the
only reason why he's done that is so
that he can
uh he can he can
Inspire the masses and and create an
opportunity where workers have more
control over their own lives and develop
autonomy and inevitably develop class
Consciousness creating ample opportunity
for uh if you uh believe in that sort of
thing socialist Revolution
right but that would never happen if the
people were were happy with their
conditions I feel like that would not
happen but anyway so let me ask you this
uh to Peg this down even more in a
socialist workplace a socialized
workplace certain jobs are still going
to get paid more than others right
yeah absolutely oh [__] okay
yeah
so there's still going to be class
they'll be class right they'll be class
distinctions in a socialist no the class
distinction is not on pay that's a
that's a a liberal uh understanding
that's actually why people be like
you're I see people like you're the rich
dude and the Porsche and I'm the and I'm
the working class dude great question
great question you don't think people
will see that so social hierarchies are
inevitable there will be different kinds
of hierarchies what you're talking about
is is perfectly valid but the class
distinction in a socialist economy is
not is is completely abolished because
the idea is and there will be those who
have and those who have not is what
you're saying at least in the end people
everyone will have but every people that
have more exactly people will have a lot
more yes some people that want to have
more will be able to have more and even
a lot more yes this is why I always be
part of a class this is why I always
talk about no because they have no
control over the lives of others in that
regard I find this idea that like people
in a socialist country who are have a
lot more they're able to make a lot more
money somehow won't be influenced by
power or influence or greed that somehow
and there's Society no matter what
happens that will turn into capitalism
is what you're saying I think there will
be a there will be these people are
going to be influencing the
concentration to benefit themselves yes
um the best way to stop that from
happening is democracy democracy in the
workplace actual like we cannot even
imagine Mark Fisher once said it's
easier to imagine the end of the world
than to imagine the end of capitalism
and he was right uh this is this is
capitalist realism because
we are having this argument
within the boundaries and within the
cultural understanding of like existing
capitalism today and the reality is
uh well there you we have no way you and
I as it stands I have no way of like
helping you try to imagine a world where
like each individual worker has more
autonomy and does not suffer from
alienation you don't think it workplace
you don't we would offer them plenty of
more educational opportunities plenty
more free time
um I guess the example you can point to
in in terms of difference uh different
degrees of socialization would be a uh a
person doing contracted work at Uber
okay to make ends meet in America versus
like a regular unionized uh factory
worker in Germany the level of autonomy
that they have and the level of of
interest that they have and the level of
Engagement that they have in a workplace
democracy or some form of it is
drastically different than the
contracted Uber employee their world
view is drastically different their
democracy yields uh drastically
different results as a consequence but
let's be realistic We're Not Gonna
spring into our alternate reality where
capitalism isn't doesn't we're not
dominate though which is why which is
why I always Advocate which is part of
why I'm saying no no because that's why
I always advocate for for that is always
advocate for in the interim Social
Democratic reforms that will yield more
opportunities for uh that will yield
more opportunities for for uh uh for
workers to organize
because I think it's interesting so in a
socialist country there's going to be
people who make a lot more
and within a company are they exploiting
their workers the only the CEO the
founder of a car company he makes a lot
more than the workers
as long as it is democratically
organized in the sense that like uh
every single person is like no you're
you're a productive output in this
circumstance is significantly higher
than us then yeah that that would be how
do they determine that
through a democratic process they have
like a vote for everybody and the
company has equal uh ballot power
uh depending on uh like how long you've
worked at the company and and things of
that nature these are different
formations at this point like this is
now we're getting into uh like how do we
organize uh our workplace and like how
much power do we give each individual
vote in the workplace yes they would
have one vote but ultimately
um what are the matters that they are
tasked with uh voting on and there's a
like even in unions there's a structure
right like every single person does have
a vote the rank and file will always
vote but there's still a negotiations
committee there's still someone engaging
in the contract negotiations there's
still elections being held inside of the
Union does that make sense it does and
but here does this make sense yeah
you're inside and I want to ask you Dan
because I I'm curious about yours
you're inside a big company let's just
say they make cars there's tons of
employees there
the the CEO founder he makes a lot more
than the employees
do you think that uh the leaders should
make more than the workers Dan
uh well it just kind of depends on lead
I mean there's
I think there's Nuance there because I
think it really depends on what what the
company looks like how it operates
um
should should the CEO who is on a
day-to-day basis working and managing a
company make more money it works the
same hours as the production people I
mean with more responsibility I think
should inherently come with some more
privilege however I mean now are we
talking about a CEO are we talking about
an owner because a lot of owners don't
do [__] no I'm talking about someone
who's working because the idea of
ownership is probably different in a
socialist right and and and and and the
owners may it may be private or even
maybe a public company and the CEO
so you you agree he should make more so
it just depends there's just there's not
room for nuance there's just not what do
you mean if you're living in a socialist
country this [__] needs to be like
laid out like there's not really in
every workplace we're going to decide
this looks like different Nuance under
capitalism where you have the freedom
but there's rules like minimum wage but
with rules exactly you would have the
similar structure uh Peg to like I'm
trying to ask you guys what the rules
like a maximum wage tied directly to
your lowest paid employees what I wanted
to say though let's say did you hear
what I said I did maximum wage tied to
like uh there there could be a situation
where like a maximum wage could be
implemented under a socialist structure
to ensure that every single workplace
has at least a maximum wage that is
directly tied to the lowest played uh
lowest paid worker and their full-blown
compensations and benefits packages yeah
let's just go back too so the the CEO he
earns more he has more responsibility oh
Hassan you said he's I don't agree with
that either no no I don't agree with
CEOs having more responsibility or
should earn more for the record what you
just said no no no no I if you're a dude
operator if you're an owner operator and
you're literally [__] I was talking
to Dan about this earlier before you got
here but it's like the difference
between what you do and the difference
between like let's say a jewelry
designer is that a jewelry designer can
Outsource their [__] labor but you
are the main product here which is why
which is very hard for you to see it I'm
using a different example yeah so if
you're a [__] jewelry designer and
you are responsible for all the
beautiful designs in your jewelry that's
like super competitive everybody loves
it everyone wants to buy your [__]
jewelry right um You can still hire
other people like designers to help uh
benefit that process
okay where everybody's altruistic yes
they vote to say the CEO should make
more money than us yes well the way that
works would be slowly but surely as you
bring on more people into your company
or as you expand and you grow okay in a
democratic capacity you are taking away
way the the earnings that you have uh
right now and eroding it because you're
giving it to some people that are coming
in because you think that they're
valuable enough to be able to pay that
way to be paid that way but that process
is being democratically voted on and
ultimately you know that you're doing
that because you're in your
understanding later down the line if you
care about this sort of thing you're
going to make even more money or rather
money is money a motivator money should
not be a motivator you're right why in
my situation CEO care if his company
makes more money it's not he's not going
to make more money
no no it's long in the long term you are
creating more stability this way because
you understand that every expansion of
your of your uh productive output okay
every single piece of expansion on your
productive output yields better
long-term stability and more money if
that's what you're [__] motivated by
but ultimately that's not the main
motivator and it should not be the main
motivator that's a horrible thing to say
if you're considering socialism that
money is a motivator that's like I think
that's like almost like taboo I feel
like no don't don't worry about what
other people say in this situation or
what you think people will perceive from
what I'm saying let me go back let me go
back because there's like because it's
irrelevant okay so let's say in our
world where the CEO makes more money
do you think it's a a possible or even
likely situation that the
the heads of these companies who make
more money are going to want to
influence the government and their
workers
to vote or support legislation that
gives them more money or more influence
is that a likely outcome
wait can you can you ask that again
within a human saying you were
rectangular and it [__] my brainer
I I think that uh I I think that yes and
I think that speaks to what Hassan was
say ah I think that's what it speaks to
what Hassan was saying earlier about why
a lot of marxists uh uh have criticism
of social democracy that that lack of
elimination of the capitalist profit
motive part of the economy it doesn't
will naturally result in what you're
saying that's my point so thank you Dan
in socialism the motive the money motive
doesn't it's literally income it's not
compatible it doesn't work because
you're gonna have people at the top who
are going to want more they're going to
want more influence they're going to
want more power they're going to want
more money and they are going to exert
their influence their status even if
they don't make more money they have
status
socialism is not egalitarian in the
sense that there's like what I'm saying
there's a problem here socialism does
not social only exists when you remove
the money motive right socialism and the
way we understand socialism yes the
money motive is is now we're talking
about now we're talking about it you
don't want to remove the money motive
because I'm in the I'm in the middle
ground where I'm talking about like what
is your Social Democrat no I'm not I'm
talking it sounds like you are I'm
talking about the realistic short-term
period because I don't live in that rig
I don't live with that with that
no listen if we if I I know that other
men can't do that for the time being if
we could uh just teleport into a utopian
Star Trek world where money doesn't
exist and everybody's equal yeah
everybody would love that but let's talk
about real [__] I am talking about real
[__]
you can do which is why I'm giving you
an example of like the inter room period
of moving towards socialization or
social uh a a socialist transition I
agree with that but but the problem is
when I describe that you say well that's
not socialism like I'm like yeah I know
money being a motivator for certain
people once you move to socialism the
system in my opinion falls apart it
doesn't work because it falls to the
same trappings because people are going
to want more power they want more
influence you're going to have
capitalistic parties thank you Lena that
are going to influence you're going to
have these external forces
even in a democratic organization
I believe the best that we can do yeah
is provide laws and regulations that
guarantees people a fair Equitable life
let me ask within that within those
rules I believe if you're operating
within those rules then you can do and
make however much money as you want if
you're operating the rules with a super
progressive tax rate and everybody's
provided for it if you want to move to a
socialist system I don't think that that
I don't think that system actually works
so the cultural differences the cultural
differences that we see in countries
that are still capitalists but Social
Democratic versus countries like the
United States of America that are hyper
individualistic and and have like very
little social democracy is the argument
that I'm making is that with more social
amenities and with higher degrees of
socialization people's attitude towards
money and money making becomes
drastically different there are
different motivators yes status can be
an important thing but that social
hierarchy but that social hierarchy
designed around status has nothing to do
with the productive output and has
nothing to do with like your material
reality it has the capacity to change
like the way people perceive you it's
like an attractive person versus like
someone who is maybe not as uh
aesthetically pleasing right those
things are going to exist like there's
always going to socialism doesn't mean
like LeBron James has to be the same
[__] height as like you know uh like
a like a five-foot person to play
basketball there's going to be different
earners there's going to be uh there is
always going to be some level of
competition this is not a bad thing this
is a good thing this is how you it's how
you innovate if there's different levels
of earners
do you agree that that seems to be
incompatible with Marx's theory of
socialism
because if no because no it's absolutely
not because it all all and correct me if
I'm wrong a song because you're more
read on this than me but all all that is
being said at the end of the day is that
people are entitled to the value that
they create if somebody creates more
value than somebody else then they are
entitled to more value the theory is
wonderful yes but and yeah and I'm
talking about we're talking about real
[__] right but when people make more
they're going to want to influence I'm
not saying everybody but again this goes
back to what I was saying last week
there's people who
are pathological
okay yes there's always bad and even in
a socialist country the sociopaths are
probably going to float to the top just
because they're willing to do everything
that other people aren't or they care
about status and power other people
don't and so these high functioning
highly motivated sociopaths are going to
want to influence government and
business democracies
to increase their power and influence
like they do now under a castle like
they do now right and that's why I think
it's not realistic to expect that not to
happen and I think the most realistic
and the best way is in between because
capitalism hold on capitalism doesn't
work we know that and I think socialism
doesn't work for the same for the same
exact thing because people are going to
want to the psychopaths are going to
want to move it and the I think the only
realistic solution is in the Middle
where you just create a Sandbox that is
good for everybody and operate within
that sandbox because everything else
seems like a fantasy to me every single
thing that you've mentioned in both of
these equations still revolve around
human greed turning humanity and the way
people operate into capitalist little
demons who are driven by profit I do
believe self-interest is a thing that
happens it's that's certainly true which
is why
you have to have certain restrictions
placed upon people that ensure that they
don't go uh they don't get out of hand
with the level of power they have the
way I describe it is this in America
people always say labor unions are
corrupt they're actually really bad they
have a rigid hierarchy and they're they
are also susceptible to nepotism this
much is true in certain labor unions
there's been a lot of reform in the
teamsters in the UAW shouts out to that
no what do you mean historically there
absolutely has been uh I mean I don't
say that about oh no I know you don't
say that about unions my point is this
though the way I counter that always is
this there's always going to be
corruption there's always going to be
you know bureaucratic red tape there's
always going to be nepotism but I would
much rather if corruption is inevitable
I would much rather have a more just and
more Equitable a more democratic process
that at the very least by it's very
designed like in the union structure
offers offers tangible benefits to the
workplace that the workers rather than
the corruption that we currently
experience on a daily basis under the
capital of the same thing I want
okay which is why I said
um
socialism with capitalist character I
also think that socialism when you
consider corruption and high functioning
sociopaths there's a lot more risk when
you when you centralize the power at the
top let's say one party or a full of for
a dictatorship or tyranny no that that I
actually don't agree with at all I think
that the Democratic process in and of
itself whether it's a multi-party system
or a single party system or a two-party
system like we have that yields like uh
results exclusively like the material
changes that are made are are done at
the behest of Corporations and the
wealthy Capital owners
um no matter what I think that a more
democratic process is always going to be
a better and more effective mechanism at
fighting against centralized power and
and sociopaths that want to assume
control I I think that if there are
again if that is an inevitability no
matter what happens I personally believe
that more of a democratic process is
going to be more effective I'll give you
an example I like democracy Dupont
chemical Dupont chemical under the
capitalist liberal Bourgeois democracy
in in uh the United States of America
was able to uh dump toxic waste into
farmlands and Destroy natural water
supplies and delicate ecosystems they
still do it to this day we have pfas the
forever chemicals right
um that is everywhere we have
microplastics all that good stuff right
in a situation where let's say Dupont
Farm Dupont chemicals was like at least
democratically organized the workers
themselves have more power to say what
the [__] are we doing you're destroying
my [__] uncle's uh you know Farm
you're destroying my backyard right and
that way they can put a stop to it or at
least demand changes to happen rather
than expect the government to turn
around and be like all right we're the
EPA we just realized that we are going
to uh government or more government
because socialism not all government
government no that's not true through
Ethan socialism is simply giving more
power to the individuals in that
regarding business you have a government
that also you're killing people
you do not have a choice you cannot run
your business this way you you cannot
yeah I mean you that that's a that's a
stronger government than we have
yeah that's like what do you think you
want a stronger government than we have
you want a strong government regulation
yeah but it's even stronger than the one
that I want that says here's your
workplace you must exist in it so you're
saying on one hand the EPA is silly
because it's not a hypothetical this is
something that actually happened EPA
said sorry we're gutted we don't have
any we don't have like enough
researchers a lot of the research that
work at EPA also end up getting jobs at
Dupont or vice versa there's always a
revolving door Tit for Tat uh regulatory
capture is something that these
corporations do in an effort to
monopolize and also improve their profit
margins as always so in that structure
the EPA basically delegated Dupont with
figuring out how toxic their pollutants
were and of course uh until a journalist
uncovered this entire thing uh they were
able to claim that these toxic
pollutants weren't as bad right so there
is no mechanism in the situation where
the answer is capitalism yeah so we just
sit there and we expect the government
that uh that is you know appointing
people into positions of power that
literally material cereal oh no listen
we expect the government to enforce
certain regulations and restrictions
that they do not because the people that
are placed into that position of power
have no interest or need in placing said
restrictions or maybe even lack the no
people in the country don't want to make
less money so maybe they don't have
access to all the data the beautiful
part about that is that at least
historically speaking what you're
describing has never happened what I
mean by that is when you look at the UAW
for example it is supposed to be in
their best interest to be anti-ev and
yet for some reason Sean Fain and the
uaw's perfectly understanding of oh
there's also and pushing for that as a
purely socialistic hierarchy where where
they make sure there's there's
Cooperative positions okay where they
make less like Mondragon is a good
example of and have they been uh have
they been levied with the task of
deciding to make less money to help the
environment yes win absolutely not not
unless
help the economy but my point is that
saying one is better than the other is
just Theory you know well we are talking
about simply Theory I think we strongly
agree that capitalism doesn't work I
think a strong EPA is great in fact I
think you'd still need an EPA in a
socialist country I don't think it
eliminates the need for that they agreed
100 which is what what I was saying is
in that social Reformation there is
actual real mechanisms of control that
can put a stop to this kind of thing
rather than
rather than power accumulating in the
hands of the few at the top of the
corporate structure that then make these
decisions I think make these hiring
practices people in the revolving door
in theory what I think in practice it
would be great as well I think your
practice would be great but I don't
think it's I don't think it's possible
but but okay so now let's go back to
this idea so first you said the theory
doesn't work now you're saying in
practice it won't work no because it's
not it's not and what I mean is that
it's you can't organize it that way it
won't work and and you know but
we do see different you and I are in
agreement that higher degrees of
socialization is a benefit okay we we're
in agreement you like unions you want
workers that have more control you want
workers that have more power more say uh
and have more autonomy ultimately so you
and I are at absolutely in agreement on
that front so to say that that doesn't
work in theory I I think betrays the
workplace specifically well yeah in the
workplace as well if you're an agreement
no that's a huge difference we spend 80
percent of our adult lives in the
workplace is the most important and I
believe it's a regular organization
listen um we we seem to have a
disagreement with about like greed like
there seems to be this notion that
people that live in a capitalist country
we ain't we understand greed and desire
for wealth
uh differently than an example we see is
like Native Americans and that's part of
why I can't conceive of a true
socialistic country you're you're saying
that like uh you know primitive
communism or primitive accumulation
which has been uh the foundation of like
societal development for much longer
than the Industrial Revolution or
post-industrial revolution capitalism
right I've seen a lot of people say that
greed is learned that if you grew up in
a pure socialist society no absolutely
self-interest is a is a real thing that
people have but people can be taught and
people can uh learn that the the
collective aspects of societal
development are far more important for
self-interest than the individual the
hyper individualistic like I'm gonna get
mine [__] everybody else so let me the
point of going to this greed discussion
is to talk about like human nature and
that innocence I believe that in a
perfect Society socialist society
there'll be forces of influence of
wealthy people people with status people
with power wanting it more for
themselves my argument and I believe
that that's it and I believe that that's
innate yeah if so first of all uh I
don't think that there's a biological
imperative I think that like I said
what's the self-interest self-interest
can be
yes so how is it how is accumulating
lots of money different than resource
Gathering or accumulation I will
describe it to you
a society that heightens
um collectivist understandings okay as a
consequence of it being directly tied to
our uh at this point our means of
production and how we understand it how
we how we uh generate Commodities is
going to have the exact opposite opinion
on collectivism versus Hyper
individualism in the way that you see it
under capitalism more people will have a
a collective understanding that like we
are in this together and that we're
working side by side
um and then yes you're right and the
reality is that there will still be
people who are self-interested people
who will still want to utilize uh the
the existing constructs the existing
hierarchies to their immediate Advantage
at the cost of others but my point is
that if that is an inevitability which I
agree because there will be people who
are sociopathic criminals okay
charlatans the lump and pros and whatnot
okay
that will always exist but even if that
exists in the hype and I'm being very
realistic about this wouldn't it be
better to have more mechanisms of
control in the form of democracy and
have to ensure a world in which everyone
has more autonomy in a place where they
spend 80 of their lives on it would be
so yeah then we're in agreement there's
a rubber band
you know it's pulling us the center of
gravity is social democracy capitalism
socialism and the rubber bands pulling
us in both directions towards the center
that's what I believe
okay
and my point always is that while
marginal incremental reform and social
democracies were made when uh there was
actually a counter force in the form of
Communists trade unionists anarchists
and the like okay they have been
thoroughly eviscerated both in this
country and in Europe as well which is
precisely the reason why you see Europe
following the American attitude with uh
with with its own uh
conditions uh getting worse and worse
year over year if you're willing to at
least acknowledge that there are going
to be innately just as a product of The
Human Condition people that are born
greedy with a with a desire to want to
hoard resources I don't know why you're
afraid to say greedy they're hoarding
resources
um if you're willing to admit that
they're going to be like black people
yeah then then that's okay for me
because there was some takes I saw no
pretended like that don't don't have a
conversation when you go on on Reddit
who also themselves will probably change
their uh ideas there's there's people
are very rigid especially under the
guise of anonymity online uh it's it's
not reflective of the the actual
conversation that you could be having
that's productive okay good I'm glad you
hear that but I yeah so let's move on I
fall into this trap too I yell at
[__] people in my child all the time
because I sometimes uh lose sight of
like sarcasm and I can't get an accurate
assessment because I don't know where
you're coming really bad okay but I want
to continue this if you if you go to pee
I'm [__] everyone's a communist after
this I'm just letting you know it's okay
maybe we should both go so you don't get
the advantage no I'm Gonna Get You don't
need to pee always people for me no I'm
holding it in
you don't need to pee yeah
oh God
not you want me to mute his mic
that's [__] up
um I'm reading I'm reading no I have
control I have control uh there you go
I think this is a I think this has been
a a relatively productive conversation I
mean God knows what people will do to
pick this apart because we're every
single time we have conversations very
frustrating that like there is a
secondary market like a like a cottage
industry of people who will like pick
apart every uh detail and make these
like Grand uh assertions off of it which
is very frustrating because it's like
like I guess if you're from one of these
communities out there and there's plenty
of them uh there's so many people that
make videos right
I mean how weird I'm not gonna say that
the HD podcast is right I mean I would
say the HP podcast we do that too you
know what I mean yeah we do that as we
do that as well yes I do that as well
but like my my question always is like
if you're coming from one of these
communities like don't you feel like
you're duped a little bit by your by
whoever you trusted into believing that
there is like genuine uh Discord and and
division here like talk about you and
Ethan uh yeah or even well people didn't
attack you as much surprisingly it was
more so me even though you and him had a
a big disagreement as far as well nobody
gives a [__] about me I mean come on uh
it was odd I don't know because you have
a lot of uh differing opinions as well
but for some reason you weren't getting
uh you weren't getting criticized as
much it's almost like people are more
self-interested in certain direction but
yeah I think there's definitely an
element of that people definitely have
it out for you and also I think I think
I saved myself a little bit by being um
uh
at the beginning I don't know if you
caught how much of that conversation you
caught but I I was very reluctant to
engage in that conversation and so you
know anything that I said was kind of
tinged with the fact that like Dan
doesn't even really want to be here so I
guess maybe that softened uh people's
anger I'm sure people did get angry
about it but frankly I was stressed
about it afterwards just because like I
I don't know I I don't like being the
center of attention and so I stayed off
of I stayed off of social media all
weekend I just didn't look at it
yeah they just said they were glazing me
up I wonder some people were but yeah
you were saying Queen Dan when they were
saying when
um you know
maybe I'll take this as an opportunity
to uh to drop a little bit of knowledge
I don't think I've ever actually shared
on the show
but knowledge
um
my uh one side of my family was actually
uh I am descended from a bunch of like
hardcore Bolsheviks in the Russian
Revolution I knew it [__] dude that's
you that's right
actually trying to draw this out of you
dude you're [__] done my last name
swerd love is a bastardization of
sverdlov who was uh one of Lenin's like
lieutenants
or you want this to go out I mean I'm
kidding we're talking like great dude
we're talking about great great uncle or
something here you know
your family's proletarian violence and
his contributions
yeah where's Zara's here how dare you
sorry sorry I didn't want me to piss off
the whites um so I yeah I know I always
see this picture and I'm always like
dude he seems a little too comfortable
in that outfit
but like he's just filling that you know
it's a Halloween costume it's a
Halloween costume
Red Scare yeah
okay so I want to move on to some more
practical topics but before we do that I
want to say
I think this is a great conversation I
agree anyone that's mad you're wrong
is upset right now about this
conversation you're just you're wrong
this is a good conversation we're having
you know people get heated but uh
on the chat and
uh really interesting okay good yeah
the last time was a little jading but I
wasn't gonna stop me but anyway also I
want to emphasize that we agree on so
much like literally 95 in in the
practical application in the short term
we are in agreement 100 of the way if
you like Bernie Sanders then you know
you're good with me that's like that's
my opinion because Americans do not have
any class Consciousness and you have to
build that there are certainly differing
opinions like people who believe in
accelerationism or whatever but I truly
think that uh America will only
accelerate towards barbarism as it has
and not necessarily socialism without
any kind of uh without people believing
that like they have any any kind of
autonomy in the workplace any kind of
means of collective bargaining in the
workplace okay so anyway my point is if
you're angry you're just you're being
silly right now this is good this is a
good conversation and on my part again
I'm come from I'm pretty you know
ignorant so this is good for me to kind
of I think you understand yourself I
think I think you are more importantly
than anyone else ignorance is is one
thing but you're very curious and you're
charitable uh when you want to learn
things and I think that that is truly
important as opposed to being like I've
made up my mind this is good I mean
obviously there's still Hang-Ups yeah
but that's always going to happen it's
it's just you know this kind of Dogma is
too powerful everyone has their own
Journey not that we have like over 30
000 people watching like a really
debate about this yes socialism and
social democracies yeah I'm happy to see
that and like Hassan said earlier I mean
I I think there's been a massive uh sea
change in this country in the last
decade largely thanks to Bernie Sanders
but I would even go further back and say
like the Occupy stuff in the financial
crisis is when it really started to
creep into the Consciousness but like I
can't imagine having this conversation
when I was like a teenager you know oh
yeah like it would be a non-starter in
this country well we're both Radical by
the way it's worth saying by yes
yourself in the eyes of the broader
American public or I would be considered
radical compared to someone like myself
yes people will go oh he seems
reasonable which I personally love I
think that that's a [__] great thing
I don't think because the more insane I
look the more sane you look and in the
short term what you're advocating for is
unironically a good thing right which is
why I also you look crazy for one I look
sane for once no but like but that's my
point is that that's why I also uh we're
working in the same that's why I also
try to engage in movement building in
the other direction as well whenever
there's like because there's plenty of
people who [__] hate me on uh to the
left of me who have like radical you
know maoist third worldest opinions or
whatever the [__] but I never give that
any kind of light or any kind of
attention or dunk on it because I feel
like yeah they look crazy or whatever
who gives a [__] ultimately if they are
working in their own way to erode the
power that Capital has then you're good
in my book and that even extends to
social Democrats to the right of me as
well
so just to summarize my point before we
move on is essentially this I believe
social democracy can address all the
issues that socialism attempts to
address
and also offers a more realistic and a
proposition for a
um
an organization of society that's it but
let's move on
um it is a 12 20 I should just point out
we've been going for about two hours
here you need to bail that's fine but I
have more I have more questions okay
what do you have I'm down to are you
talking can I just point this out real
quick you sent this a moment ago yeah
ladies and gentlemen we got them every
time every time one of my favorites to
be fair predictons has gotten me as well
my parents every time we do a clickbait
title they go Dan left baby died baby's
dead maybe he's dead what yeah and in
the role of a lifetime Gary all right
let's talk about some like realistic or
not realistic let's talk about some
actual applications of of socialism
today because I kind of want to
understand it
so let's look at China
so I know China's done a lot of good for
the massive amount of its populance
they've uplifted them out of poverty
they gave them access to health and
housing and on the whole the um improved
literacy rates yeah everything okay
rapid organization rapid development the
um exactly the the quality of life of
the average Chinese person is absolutely
uh
catastrophically improved okay now you
tell me when I ask you is she's pretty
radical for you to even admit that in my
opinion but okay well hold on I I'm not
I've never denied that okay but what I
my question is you is China socialist or
not because you always say China isn't a
socialist country I think China if you
ask them is a transitional social estate
um do I do I think that it has certain
socialist characteristics in China
what do you mean you said if you ask
them the CCP government that's like
that's their main thing is that this is
like they say socialism with Chinese
characteristics we are a transitional
socialist state every Communist party
will always say that they are uh trying
to implement a transitional social
estate obviously that socialism has to
be adjusted to the material conditions
and the needs that the people have uh
because so so last week you were telling
me China isn't a socialist country so I
was asked I was curious what you meant
by that it's not socialism in the sense
that like there is collective ownership
over the means of production across the
board it's uh it's state ownership that
benefits the interests of the citizens
as you've also uh admitted or recognized
I'm not it's not an admission yeah I
reckon it's an admission if you're
living in the western world because in
the western world they're unreliable
it's just a fact
yeah but people will use here comes I'm
not one of those people I'm not one of
those people you know you know what I
mean okay
so
well okay here's what I'll say about
Taiwan here's what else statements hold
on we'll get to that before we get okay
here's what I'll say about China
's economy was extremely stagnant
for a long time and even if you compare
it to Taiwan who separated from them in
about 1950s if you compare well
more to that separation I think
sorry there's a little bit more to that
separation I think well we'll get into
more depth than that but my point is
around the uh 1970s 1980s is when
China's economy started to Boom yes and
the reason for that boom was because
they started to open up their economy
and lean into more capitalistic
Notions they and from they got an influx
of foreign Capital yes and that is when
the average quality of life of the
average Chinese person was vastly
improved so here before that the Chinese
economy was extremely stagnant and the
quality of life was not good yeah so
here's how that works right
um there is plenty of trade that occurs
with other countries as well that do not
have a a mandate of of trying to do even
development right let's not use the word
socialism here let's just say uh
urbanization even development like
uplifting Chinese people will say
Chinese Prosperity right
um plenty of other countries that get
foreign Capital do not necessarily
develop in that in that direction in the
same way that China did the reason why
China was able to do so is not
necessarily because foreign Capital came
into the country it was because of what
they did with said foreign Capital if
China had developed in this similar
structure with like you know
western-backed klept rats that control
it like an oligarchy in the same way of
the of the democratized market in the
dissolution of the USSR did then China
would objectively be in a similar
situation to Russia and the Russian
economy in general
um Russia made all of its or the USSR
made all of its uh of its
collectivization in that time frame in a
very short time frame without 400 years
of like slavery and and uh uh and and
all of the many benefits that that gave
to the Western World and and went from
[__] potato Farmers to uh people that
beat uh the United States uh to the
space to be the first person to go to
space you're a Gaga and shouts out uh
similar structure existed and similar
thing happened in China as well after
foreign Capital came in but it wasn't
necessarily because the foreign Capital
came in it was what they did with that
foreign Capital does that make sense so
in that situation because money is just
money right if there was like uh I don't
know if we lived in a very mining world
of money for it was for cheap labor yes
yes absolutely and so in a sense they're
serving capitalism they're taking the
money it was a survey the Dingus Gambit
is that uh that utilizes it
it's just like utilizing the the thing
was the leader interesting oh that was
his name Dingus
um uh is that uh you can take advantage
of uh
Western Society has uh has has this uh
division of power where uh there's a
there's an imbalance there where Capital
owners and their their Capital interests
are better represented by their
Bourgeois government so they will if we
offer them you know cheap manufacturing
and then take their IP uh and and start
slowly but surely developing our country
through uh through Rapid urbanization
like taking all that foreign capital and
like building roads uh building
hospitals building trains and and
whatnot uh we will be able to inevitably
improve our material conditions as a
collective in doing so they've also
entrenched themselves in a capitalistic
model I think and not totally right but
to an extent and I think to that extent
it was a great benefit to them to
operate in that middle ground and I'll
say this since that's happened uh you
know that's when we you started seeing
all these Chinese billionaires which is
not a good thing I'm saying but it's
global capitalism that's that's the
that's the inevitability it's impossible
to escape global capitalism under a
global capitalistic structure unless you
are forced to exist or operate outside
of those boundaries in the form of like
Cuba for example well we both agree on a
realistic uh approach so in that sense
we agree that that's why I believe
social democracy is the way but you know
Abe wrote something if you want to read
it
oh yeah uh we were saying about how the
CCP um
oh you I didn't see the second part
since established in 1921 CCP has
proclaimed himself to be a Marxist
leninist party and has consistently
referred to its system as socialism with
Chinese characteristics
in snccp views itself as
overseeing a transitional socialist
State working towards the eventual
realization of communism
because communism is a bit different
it's not like when you have like a
strong central leader no communism is
when when after a successful uh stage of
development in a transitional socialist
State uh where the the
um the scarcity problem has been solved
and uh and and there is no interest in
like uh capital accumulation and the
state eventually Withers away uh
yielding a borderless moneyless
stateless society it's the Star Trek
future you were talking about earlier
yeah but not nine as well entirely
because there's the critics often point
to the gap between the party's rhetoric
and the realities of it noting the
prominence of capitalistic practices
wealth Gap and the and the absence of
political freedoms as challenges to
their characterization as a transitional
socialist state but isn't that just like
okay but we kind of agree on that so let
me ask you this
um one of the reasons that China is able
to govern so effectively and we agree
they get [__] done fast yeah and that's
how part of again how their economic
growth was so um
so quick and strong it can act don't
have to be bogged down by
Congress and [__] can I can I cut in
here really quickly that's a dangerous
prospect that capitalist countries are
also uh Reckoning with for the record
and under a capitalist country if they
want to continue consistently competing
with China for example one of the things
that the EU did recently was uh talk
about the government-backed subsidies
and in the form of EVs and how Chinese
development is impossible to compete
with because they're offering insane
subsidies that offer Chinese EVs and and
is like basically uh destroying the EV
Marketplace for European car
manufacturers so they want to create an
investigative team and and stop that
from happening somehow or possibly even
Implement tariffs by the way that in and
of itself makes the Chinese centralized
planning structure significantly better
than capitals ones in the form of global
trade that will create in my opinion a
very scary future for the West liberal
democracies where how do you implement
that kind of central planning which
already exists but how do you make it
worse fascism
okay and well that's what I'm genuinely
afraid of well I mean China's not that
far off from it in its current state
what do you mean with like I mean they
have basically a all-powerful leader
everything's owned by the government the
only difference is they're not at War
basically that's the only missing Factor
no they are building their military
and threatening countries like Taiwan
they're pretty close to Fascism right
now they're they're building their
military uh government rules culture but
what they've done with that military is
very different than what uh the American
Military okay they have a large military
and they're threat it's always a
hypothetical and it's the same way
China's not that far from fascism it's
the same with it's like right it's not
that far from fascism America is
literally 10x the Nazi Germany fascism
though kindness closer
they have a government control of
business manufacturing okay of social
life of the press okay okay I have one
strong these are authoritarian yes these
are authoritarian constructs for sure
and then
missing from that is basically they have
they have a national they have strong
nationalism I agree with that and they
have a and the only difference basically
now to go full Fashions is if they were
uh invading countries what they're
threatening to do right now so on the on
that same metric you realize that the
only difference in America is the simple
feeling that you are free and that you
have all manner of different freedoms
whereas we have freedom we do have
freedoms of we have freedom to say
freedom of I agree religion we have
freedom of assembly those are big deals
but I know you don't think you don't
want to no no those are huge deals yeah
okay of course no of course this is
something I willingly recognizes that's
why I say like I'm not living in [__]
China right now it's not like their own
cities to say well oh America is yeah
and I'm not being an American simple I'm
just saying that
American fascism like China's China
fascism is better okay here's the here's
the difference because fascism okay
fascism is supposed to be a a means of
control with a with a oftentimes
capitalist uh understanding of the
economy to and effectively to organize
the economy and continue organizing the
economy capitalism doesn't have a lot to
do with fascism I don't think capitalism
has everything to do with fascism I mean
capitalism you're striking on one of the
biggest uh political philosophy debates
of the 20th century
whipping the [__] masses a lot of
people Define fascism as capitalism in
crisis yes so so I think about it more
about like
um yeah maybe it's maybe it's like
capitalism gone [__] totally on all
the rules maybe yeah yeah
nothing to do with capitalism then all
of these supposedly populations
who started off as like supposedly
quote-unquote socialist or even like you
know uh interested in in higher levels
of socialization would not have worked
alongside Capital owners and destroyed
trade unions and Communists in general
those were the first people that they
[__] butchered okay fine I don't care
about uh capitalism I mean I'm a Social
Democrat so are in terms of like how uh
I just say I don't think social
Democrats in Germany there's also I
think contention there but I don't think
Chinese fascism is better or worse in
America why is that funny
because I don't think that I do not
think that China is fascist I think that
they are authoritarians I don't think
China is closer to Fascism than America
I mean not because yeah I think it's the
most significant part but like the most
significant part that you're mentioning
is like oh they're building their
military and they don't have freedom of
assembly or freedom of speech well they
they control the culture yes this part
this part is correct the manufacturing
nationalism is the best part that you
can actually identify in the in the
problems with China you can absolutely
push that I don't see where's that part
where it is it is nationalistic okay
however uh the the the Chinese
development and and Chinese military
action is either irredentus in nature
which is different than Imperials where
it's like it's more so uh expansive in
its own limited area rather than Global
imperialism which is Express effort with
the the bat Taiwan they're all okay well
Tibet in Taiwan and then not expect me
to to explain I'm not ready for this
tangent because okay Ethan but like go
ahead go ahead Tibet was literally a
[__] feudal slave uh mandate
like autonomous zone I'm trying to do
them a favor that was one I mean in
America when I say something like this
people get very upset you know if you
talk about the Dalai Lama saying suck my
tongue or whatever but like that's not
far from the norm in [__] normal
Tibetan existence before the Communist
Party came in and and
unilaterally
took over Tibet like their culture
they basically are trying to you know
homogenize the culture if your culture
they're trying to spoil the religion and
the part the part of the party they did
the Warlords in slavery abolishing that
yes I do think that that is good no
China did them a favor I think that yes
I will be on the record it's just like
America did it that while the Chinese
government wait
I'm not going to say it well there is no
there is no equivalent in American
intervention that you can point to in a
similar capacity unless you're talking
about okay so and I think this is a good
uh this is a good way to describe Taiwan
as well the American Federal Government
going into the [__] South and killing
unfortunately not all of them but a
decent amount of flavors and Defenders
of slavery this is violent retribution
from a powerful federal government
squashed that squashed okay Tibet is the
south in the Civil War yes
Tibet in the in the time frame where
Chinese intervention happened would be
the South yesterday the moral aspect of
the war of China the interests uh are
are obviously like National Security or
whatever the [__] they uh claim but but
ultimately the reality was uh that
beyond the the uh material benefits that
yes they were a feudal oppressive uh uh
slavery-backed uh State autonomous
region so just like just like um
Russia's denotsifying Ukraine no I don't
agree with that for the record I don't
think that Russia is denouncing Ukraine
if anything there they will end up
notifying Ukraine in the long run if you
want to point to a modern uh country
that you could probably fairly
characterize as fascists I would point
to Russia before I agree 100 I think
that Russia is a significantly better
example of a of a fascist nation-state
given its uh modern Russia contemporary
Russia being a capitalist nation state
built by oligarchs that were anti-soviet
and anti-communist that made deals with
Western bankers and and westerners
originally uh leading up to the
dissolution of the USSR so they could
literally pick apart the entire country
Vladimir Putin being another primary
example of this okay good they're
fascists I would agree that Russia's
interests are significantly more fascist
than the outcomes are because their
interests do not lie around improving
their productive forces or or the
abolition of like uh like what Russia is
doing in Ukraine is no different than
what America has done in Iraq like oh
we're bringing democracy like they're
not denotsifying Ukraine it's [__]
[__] whereas I will not say the same
thing about like uh well
you can create a pretense to take any
anything you want you know yeah but
there are but there are also but you
agree like for example the the federal
government uh in the Civil War did the
right thing right it was very violent
but if they did the right thing yeah
would you agree with that yes okay good
so let's talk about Taiwan then because
Taiwan in its formation is uh created by
the kmt uh that uh or kmt general uh
Chang haishek
I'm butchering the his name I think that
was close but I think it's the closest I
can get to that and it's for in its
formation it was a military dictatorship
that was fascist openly fascist openly
Nationalist and there was no surprise
there that uh the American government
was backing them right in its entire
Inception now is very different than
that yeah I don't know a lot but this is
very important talking about Taiwan
should they be invaded for how they were
absolutely not right absolutely not
because hey guess what everybody was
when America when America builds you up
to be a nation as a counter a
counterbalance or or as a as a the real
uh China as we did originally that's why
we were in support of Taiwan because
they were nationalist fascists military
dictatorship that was brutal uh
comprised of dudes that got owned by
[__] Mao uh overall right but at a
time and in a time when
um yeah 100 at a time and they were butt
hurt losers that believed that like
Hmong Mongolia is also a part of
Republic of China they have more
expansive desires more expansive
territorial desires than Mongolia than
that they can't do anything they're
military according to American generals
assessments was [__] dog [__] I think
taiwan's a better example then so but
Taiwan but wait I'm not ready but Taiwan
in its institution tangent is out of
control wait but but like you're you're
you want me to just we'll go back to it
these things don't happen overnight if
you assume that it's like a war between
good and bad or that it happened
overnight it materialized that of
nothing then yes it is that is
infinitely more susceptible to Western
framing to be like these are the good
guys these are the bad guys they want to
do this thing and then you make
comparisons to like reasonable Wars or
whatever and then all of a sudden we are
not factoring in the understandable
whether I agree with it or not doesn't
matter the understandable desires of
national security from the Chinese
nation-state that is is in an openly
contentious yet still very favorable
trade relationship with the Western
world old why the [__] would they want a
American military base in a nation-state
that was developed by America originally
a fascist nationalistic uh brutal
military dictatorship why would they
want that to be an American base one
mile off their [__] Coast okay you're
right so that is precisely the reason uh
uh so that's precisely the reason why
the the people of Taiwan who recognize
that reality while they yearn for
Independence they recognize that reality
that it will never happen as long as
China has a military or a powerful
economy and and as long as America has a
legitimate interest in Taiwan being an
American uh base of of uh support to
inevitably control China dominate China
in some ways okay hold on let me go back
because we did like the monster tangent
here okay I was saying one of the
reasons China is so effective is because
of their one-party state
um
you know without opposition they're able
to move fast and effectively so do you
think this is a good model
um
do you think the one-party state is a
good model because the outcome of that
one party state is also massive human
rights violations across the board I
mean I don't think that uh I think that
America is a one-party I don't care
about America no but it's important to
understand because like the one-party
state is an inevitability under any kind
of formation of the government the
government is going to yield results
that are either positive for the people
or negative for the people even if it's
a marginal there is still a difference
even if it's marginal there's still
difference for example abortion which I
consider a human right it's it's
marginal I agree with you on that I
think that it but I don't want to talk
about America I want to talk about China
well the reason why we're talking about
America is to put it into a framework
that is understandable like that that's
the only reason why I always bring up
people always say Hassan your only
assessment on the situation is America
bad it's significantly more nuanced than
that the reason why I always go back to
America is to help Americans or
westerners understand uh Chinese
governance not all that different they
you say they don't just pretend to have
two parties yeah no no I disagree with
that I don't think it's like super super
wrong I think there are marginal
differences in the parties and I do
think there's space potentially although
super unlikely it's happened in American
history for a third party it's probably
never going to happen again but it has
happened before yeah the Civil War
and so but like the consequence of the
greatest material differences okay but
the greatest material differences were
ever represented in American history was
during the Civil War okay
the greatest material difference is like
genuine material differences in the form
of how to produce cheap Commodities like
cotton okay well in in uh the northern
states uh they backed the abolition of
slavery Southern States didn't that was
a major point of contention that was
probably one of the last times where
there was like a real and significant
difference in an agreement I guess a
difference in opinion that led to a very
violent uh conquest of the South that
wanted to secede and was forced to not
um the one-party system in China does
result in a lot of human rights
violations does the does the ends
justify the means in that case I don't
think it's control I don't think it does
okay I think that in in Cuba which also
has a certain restrictions on civil
liberties for example
uh there is uh there is a better
argument to be made that the ends
justify the means in Cuba because you
know Cuba is an island that has been
under embargo and uh since its
inceptions is the Cuban Revolution after
we you know we backed Batista and wanted
to make sure that ensure that Cuba was
still a tourism destination and sugar
plantations with slavery uh and then
lost we immediately said okay [__] this
[__] Cuba you we are gonna do everything
in our power to stop you from developing
in that situation because it's a tiny
island nation that is in the ass cheeks
of the largest imperialist superpower on
the planet it's understandable to have
certain uh it's understandable to have
certain restrictions on civil liberties
whereas or not and by the way ironically
Cuba is like way better on abortion gay
rights and whatnot which we can get into
if you want no that's a that's a
consequence of direct democracy even
though Cuba is a one-party State as well
okay like I mean there's plenty of cute
I know plenty and again I'm not super
familiar with that the politics so I I
don't even want to speak on it
necessarily just because I don't know a
lot I do know that a lot of Cubans that
I've met [__] hate
the Cuban government yeah because
they're in America they're not like Rich
they're like no no it doesn't matter
okay so they're like they don't have to
be rich they're but they're in America
which means admittedly I don't know I
don't know like they had a disagreement
in the latest terms they either were
forced to uh to run away or literally
had in the lightest terms a disagreement
with the Cuban government so of course
they are not going to be fond of of okay
the current Cuban so uh government isn't
there when you're looking at a country
like China who's able to act so
efficiently and if you're looking for
some democratization or like some
equality of outcome in terms of income
for the lowest people
seems like a
a a potential and almost like inevitable
outcome is some of the stuff that you
see in China like
um one cultural identity one religion or
non-religion like this need to be
homogeneous so that people are compliant
and they live that way this is State
development 101. every every nation
state does so the reform the reason that
that has happened in China is why all
these mass human rights violations are
able to exist like re-educating people
Mass detention for people who are
religious you know what I mean
um
forced labor camps they [__] and I
know you deny that they organ they are
organ harvesting but I do believe that
they do do that or did do that maybe
they stopped organ harvesting yeah organ
harvesting did happen in China what
you're talking about is like falun gong
propaganda which is that they have a oh
no well there's two different types what
we're talking about is like yeah were
there criminal components and and
certainly people sponsored Oregon no I
don't know if it was state-sponsored or
evidence suggests that it was the state
actually watch out oh she's right behind
you sorry it's okay
um if it was state sponsored the state
would not have cracked down on it
inevitably well they did we realize how
bad it looks it was that evidence
why would they care about how bad it
looks you said that they know labor
camps China doesn't care about
appearance oh well they do to it if
they're authoritarian why would they
care well I mean they have labor camps
which is by the way ironic because
America still has a much higher prisoner
density than any other Nation on the
planet and slavery is not abolished in
America we can't criticize
well my point is yes it's wrong in China
as well but it's of course it's wrong in
China as well okay forget about forget
about that I mean look like what about
the but what about for example now
you're doing What About Us by the way no
I'm not I'm gonna tell you why I'm
specifically let's use this and now this
example because it's the best one the
the uyghur um I'm sorry I don't know how
to say their name detention camps were
they re-educated and eliminated their
Ultra identity and relation and also
frankly as a there it's almost
impossible to do that and not like
think of them as others were they also
you know are under horrible horrible
horrible Mass surveillance even
including like certain uh
Representatives living with people in
families like some of this is like
people will say oh this is Adrian Zen's
propaganda and some of it is very real
100 uh propaganda to be like it wasn't
as bad
I'm not saying it wasn't as bad good
because I thought you said but hold on
no I think that my analysis on on the
matter is is
fairly nuanced but still incredibly
critical of the Chinese State I have
never said that mass surveillance Mass
imprisonment even execution in certain
instances and China's development in
China they're homogeneous socialist
society the reason that the Chinese
nation state claims they did this and Xi
Jinping famously even I forget when he
said this this is a while back but
basically said something along the lines
of like we learned how to deal with uh
we learned how to deal with with uh
Islamic Terror from the American nation
state okay uh and and that is why we had
to deal with the uyghurs I don't agree
with what they did I think that it's
[__] [__] you think it's
necessary to maintain their socialist
homogeney it's not a socialist
homogeneous now we're talking about
cultural homogeny right that's what
you're saying but it's all yeah it's all
it's connected the the separatist
movement uh within uh xinjiang and and
some of the aspects of that did include
uh you know uh knife attacks and and the
like they don't have a lot of guns in
China luckily
um this like uh the criminal component
of that uh should have been dealt with
on an individual basis rather than
dragnets and Collective punishment for
the entirety of xinjiang which is what
China did and re-education camps and
mass surveillance which exists still to
this day xinjiang or any kind of
separatist movement in xinjiang has now
been absolutely squawked destroyed
eviscerated and and uh not only have
they done that but also on top of that
they've basically softened like you said
or uh I guess the term that westerners
who uses honified xinjiang uh and and
have now and now use their like uh uh
their their cultural output as like an
export even like you could just go to
xinjiang and see uh how how wonderful
everything is that kind of thing
um oh here oh you found it God damn
that's so funny Mr G urged the party to
emulate aspects of America's war on
terror after the September 11th attacks
from documents leaked in 2019.
just to just to frame this for people
that aren't familiar with the history
that the the
crackdowns over there were a result of a
rise in terrorism in that region there
were bombings and stuff going on and so
all those camps and and the re-education
all of that was a response it was
essentially a Crackdown and but it was a
completely for the record completely
unjustifiable way over the top [__]
Dragnet yes I right exactly yeah or or
what the United States did in
Afghanistan after September 11th I mean
we we rocked to that country for 20
years as a result of the terrorism
defending America or something that's
really funny you should say that because
that is the automatic position of people
in the west though is that like whenever
I make a comparison to America like if I
compare Russia to America people think
I'm doing that to defend Russia and it's
like no that is the worst comparison I
can make for a country's actions because
my opinion on American uh the American
superpower is is that it is incredibly
bloody and Incredibly unjust but the
reason why people immediately go uh say
what the [__] why are you uh bringing up
America in this situation is because
they inherently without recognizing it
will defend American foreign policy
because they are under the understanding
I agree most people do that yeah but so
my ultimate question is do you believe
that this um cultural homogeney is is uh
required in a
socialist or communist yes I think that
some form of positive uh social cohesion
needs to occur if you are going to build
a nation-state and this happens in
public education I'm I think that public
education is very valuable and I'm 100
in agreement if it's being done in a
more positive in a more positive way
through public education then it's great
right but not like not like erasing
their ethnic identity yeah if they're
doing it in a negative way in that
situation where like education moves to
re-education a positive a positive
component would be something that we
unfortunately do not have in America
either would be to uh to to
to have uh regions that that still have
their own uh ethnic identities preserved
through their own board of education and
and uh are allowed to exist this is a
major problem with the USSR as well this
happened in the USSR where there was a
russification of all the the nation
states that were under the banner of the
USSR which ended up creating a [__] ton
of division uh and and also uh a a uh
like suppression of religious freedom
religion is something that is so
personal and so important for human
beings and their identity isn't Mark's
theory around like we have to get rid of
a religion
um that's no I mean the the I no and
also I don't even care what I don't even
care what Marx's own personal
perspective on religion is ultimately
because I'm saying I'm looking at real
implementations of socialism throughout
historical uh materialist socialist
nation-states and I'm saying that that's
bad and wrong it is demonstrably bad it
was bad in Afghanistan it was bad in the
USSR and it's certainly bad when China
does the same exact [__] so you're
saying yes it's required but nothing
different than what you see in in
countries today that's that's it yeah
they're good yes allowing people to have
a natural identity allowing people to
have a national identity while
simultaneously reinforcing their their
you know ethnic differences or uh their
diversity of culture is absolutely a
necessity for nation-state development
if you want this nation state to succeed
and I'm giving an example of why it
didn't work work in in the USSR by the
way I would urge you to look more into
the organ harvesting thing because I do
believe that that did happen by the
state they were harvesting the the
Muslims organs man like the wait time on
the on the um
but you're saying in modern China no not
modern China I don't think well it was
modern China it wasn't that long ago but
I don't think they're doing it you're
saying the state was harvesting the
organs of of Muslims yeah who were in
that detention Camp too to uh give to
their citizens
that dude the wait time for Oregon here
listen to this one of the most cited
pieces of evidence is the rapid growth
of China's organ transplant industry in
the early 2000s with much shorter
waiting time for organs than other
countries Chinese government has
attributed this to the use of organs
from executed prisoners but the critics
argue that those numbers do not match up
the prisoners of conscious uh yeah so
backgrounds literally can't I'm sorry if
it was in the early 2000s it would have
been before the Crackdown in on the ugh
I don't know when it sounds like it was
just the general prison population there
was a criminal component I'm not saying
that when did that happen organ
harvesting certainly happened there was
a black market for organs 100 not just
for Chinese citizens mind you that is
like literally massaging The Narrative
to fit uh the the uh like the the the
ugurus being harvested for Oregon
because it's respectful
yeah they're [__] turkey yeah like
it's called it's turkistan you know what
I mean right it's not like my my the
other side of my family my mother's side
is literally their last name is so this
is not like random individuals that I uh
like I have no Affinity towards that I'm
saying like the Chinese nation state
should oppressively [__] I'm just
saying so it's always additionally funny
when some [__] dumb [__] from Iowa is
trying to tell me about [__] muslim
oppression why don't you care about
Muslim oppression than John it's like
what the [__] are you saying anyway
sorry I get very heated about this
because like people are so merciless
just like people are merciless with you
when they say you're a [__] Tyrant or
you're a capitalist pig dog or whatever
the [__] people are infinitely more
merciless when you deviate from the
foreign policy Norms that have been
mandated by uh Americans through our
mainstream media okay so in short I
think I got my answer on that which is
you know the China Tribunal
okay whatever I want to move on to
Taiwan so last time I just want to point
out it's one o'clock we're pretty far
over already yeah okay I mean it's fine
we can we can okay
very good so I'm perfectly fine talking
about this okay great great love that so
last time we were talking about Taiwan
you had mentioned one country two
systems what did you mean by that
because I don't know anything about that
when you when you said it but I've read
it so yeah so since the Nixon era of
normalizing relations with uh China
America's understanding of China has
been that it is one over-encompassing
nation and that uh Taiwan uh which
certainly does want an independence
movement or has a as a robust
Independence Movement is simply Chinese
Taipei the American understanding of the
global understanding is the same that
there is a different autonomous
organization inside of Taiwan an
autonomous government inside of Taiwan
but it's still under the Chinese
umbrella my opinion on the matter does
not deviate away from the American
foreign policy on the matter and the
reason for that is because it also does
not deviate away from the Taiwanese the
collective Taiwanese understanding on
the matter which is that if
there's two different forces here at
play
Taiwan Independence is not something
that even Anthony blinken or the
American state backs why because it
would be incredibly disruptive to to our
largest trade partner great the people
of Taiwan want independence yeah in the
future possibly in the future the reason
why they take that position well if you
were to ask them without any sort of
Chinese influence like without any sort
of like mainland China influence would
you want independence tomorrow they
would say yes that is the majority
opinion well what they say is that we
already have the independence they said
we already had china has no influence
over Taiwanese economy or government yes
and yet but and yes and yet from a
Global Perspective they are still
considered to be Chinese Taipei right
because people doesn't want to rock the
boat exactly Taiwanese and that is my
perspective as well we are already
independent
so then there's no additional need for
State intervention from Western forces
there well but China is you know China
is what it is um
being a uh provocative what are they
doing with the Taiwanese what are they
doing that you would consider to be
provocative towards the time I mean they
have military station around they're
making they're doing War Games you know
where Taiwan is in proximity to Mainland
China right it's one mile off their
Coastline so whenever people say America
China is obvious though China is
violating their airspace we know what we
China says it China the government even
says it that we're gonna [__] take
Taiwan if y'all don't
play ball yes
China no matter if I agree with this or
not right because I want I want autonomy
for uh the people that I want to want
them to do whatever the [__] they want
self-governance right so
I understand that and I also
simultaneously understand one the
history of the the Taiwanese nation
state being propped up and and why it
was propped up and more importantly than
that I understand that the Chinese
government which is a different
government than ours right they are
human beings over there that have their
own concerns is not going to want a
[__] American Military Base one mile
off of their Coastline that is a
perfectly reasonable thing to never want
and given the historical reasons as to
how Taiwan has has been created as a
separate nation state with its own
expansionist interest in the Republic of
China the entire mainland China
including Mongolia uh that's like its
founding mandate that it is
understandable for China to not want
that to happen which is why they
constantly counter American saber
rattling with their own version of saber
rattling this does not mean that the
Chinese state is nice this does not mean
that the Chinese state is is uh genuine
or wants to implement communism Taiwan
what 30 U.S troops are stationed there's
no way you think that that is I don't
know material I don't know what you read
is offering Taiwan 30 U.S taiwan's
entire standing army would not exist
without U.S support since its Inception
okay but their America you say America
has a military base there is one of the
and that would be no no no but I don't
know I don't want it to turn
I do not want further conflict the
people of Taiwan do not want further
conflict which is why the overarching
assessment is like we're independent we
want to maintain Independence we want to
be fully independent but we don't want
to rock the boat but it seems like if
China was to and just invade Taiwan and
like look we're over it would be
devastating it would be awful for Taiwan
it would be awful for China it would be
horrifyingly bad
it'll be it would be disastrous if we
are in agreement right there right yeah
okay so we both want no further
Bloodshed to happen
and that's what the people of Taiwan
also say they want as well you also kind
of see where China's coming from
I absolutely understand why China would
feel like this is a major issue with
their National Security concerns the the
example I will give you is this let's
say just like England and and uh France
tried to do during the Civil War because
they had material interest in the cotton
trade uh continuing with uh chattel
slavery let's say they offered material
support to the southern states that
wanted to secede right in order to
continue slavery okay and they were
actually successful to a certain degree
because third parties like Imperial
Japan were also invading uh Mainland
America okay in this process so the
Civil War ended in a way where chattel
slavery continued in the South and every
abolitionist was executed and they
called it instead of white Terror let's
say they called it Black Terror okay
they executed mercilessly and ruthlessly
any abolitionist that lived in the South
and then after after
years and years of this fascist white
supremacist implementation hyper
nationalist implementation the southern
states that had successfully seceded
okay kept building a robust military
apparatus through Surplus military
supplies and weapon systems that other
countries that were foreign adversaries
to the United States of America started
giving them even more and more of this
and then and and also said the real
America is the South America southern
states are the real America and they
will one day take over the rest of
America you're saying and that they will
inevitably they will inevitably take
over the rest of America and that's
going to be the real America we're going
to help them do that and then you're
saying Taiwan is comparable to the South
succeeding Taiwan and its Inception is
identical to the South how long after
the South seceded did the War begin
what do you mean how long before between
the South seceding and the Civil War
happening I mean there was there was a
period there was a there was a period of
time no no there was a period of time
leading up to that where there were
abolitionist movements that happened
that's why people say that John Brown's
like execution Taiwan was independent
pivotal point I mean they've been
separate for a long time no yeah no I
understand which is why I'm saying like
imagine if the South was able to
successfully secede yeah right and in
America
Northern America no Northern America is
like we're worried about our own [__] we
can't [__] deal with South America
right now right like Northern America
the the you know the the Federation
let's say okay is now working on
improving their own productive forces
doing trade deals and and whatnot with
the rest of the world and they start
rapidly urbanizing rapidly developing
okay and you know the New Deal only
happens there or whatever the [__]
meanwhile the southern states are
entirely propped up by a foreign
adversary okay that is infinitely more
powerful than Northern America
and and they kept they keep saying we're
going to take over the entirety of
America is one America okay
because the northern because the
northern states are able to improve
their conditions have favorable trade
deals with the rest of the planet they
inevitably get to a point where they
want to maintain their uh hegemony they
want to maintain their security their
National Security do you think it would
be appropriate uh do you think it would
be appropriate to rock the boat per se
and allow the South to continue
developing and continue having a massive
military and and uh inevitably like you
send you send envoys like Nancy Pelosi
to Southern American states to [__]
say hey look there's they're Democratic
now like yeah sure they were designed
around slavery but they're they have a
democracy now and I think that it's okay
it's okay and appropriate to [__] uh
keep building their military make it as
robust as possible seceded just because
we were talking about it it was like
three months between the war and leading
up the build up to that was yeah
definitely longer yeah okay so I I
understand your position on Taiwan I get
I get all that you know from a for from
a uh
California is silly though because
living in California you personally
understand it right like living in a
blue State you understand why that would
be like genuinely uh like you would
understand how blue states in America
would have security concerns if like
Southern States had seceded successfully
and kept saying like no the rest of
America Is Ours after they [__] lost
too
well I mean this was 70 years ago that
Taiwan Taiwan now is not a [__]
fascist uh National I don't think the
military I don't think that how it was
founded matters at all 70 years is not
significant in development it's of
course it's that's my point no it's it's
what do you mean I'm not I don't think
that you should be like oh yeah Taiwan
is a bunch of losers that went and
started their own country and like uh so
they don't know they're not entitled to
National to a national identity I don't
think that matters 70 years is is a blip
in time in in as far as like
as far as talking about a [__] Empire
or a history that spans over like I
don't care but that doesn't matter right
we're talking about human beings yeah
and now they're now they are democratic
which is great and I understand their uh
want in autonomy and not being uh under
uh like some form of of uh crushing
civil liberties that the Chinese State
well one country two systems that's not
a real thing
what do you mean it's not a real thing
it's one country one system like in Hong
Kong that's what they want to do they
say they say Taiwan we'll do the one
country two systems but that's that's
propaganda
would it no but that's the that's the
American policy which they did with
China they have
America said that they would not uh
support an independent Taiwan and that
Taiwan is a part of China
but internally Taiwan still has autonomy
which is what is currently happening and
the Chinese State sees it as a a
autonomous region that is still under
the Chinese Banner that ends up getting
uh military support from you know
Western forces
let's talk about Ukraine and then that's
my final one okay so we were talking
about Ukraine and um your your position
was that the support for Ukraine is 100
manufactured no that's what you said
last time no I think that all all matter
of American foreign policy is greatly
influenced by manufacturer consent
because of our interest in uh you know
doing whatever the [__] we want to do
there whether it be like bringing
Ukraine into the Western sphere of
influence or or uh you know it's not
it's not genuine uh because they want
like genuine emancipation for ukrainians
so what so last time you guys compared
it you said well nobody gave a [__]
about Georgia when that got invaded
therefore
you know the fact that anyone cares
about Ukraine is feels like okay it's
not even just you guys know that but you
guys realize there's like a massive I
didn't know anything about the Georgian
War I learned about it there's a huge
difference you guys understand well I
mean the scale is a five-day weather
yeah
drop in five days and if it did we
probably wouldn't be talking about it
because that's true that's true so like
that what happened was Ukraine mounted
this uh miraculous defense and they've
got Russia a fascist country on the back
foot and we all like when fascism I
don't I don't think Russia is on the
back foot I think it's just like
extending all harm and and only
furthering we conflicted so much and I I
stand with the Ukrainian people because
I pref I like I think Ukraine is a is a
Force for good in the world they're
they're on can I I think right can I
just stop you for a second because you
said 100 manufacturer consent like
that's what you said nothing is genuine
I said 100 manufacturing consent is a
like leading role in this
reason why no no the reason why I take
issue with this is because it's like
it's like stating like I don't give a
[__] about Ukraine of course I give a
[__] about people in Ukraine uh I want
the I want the war and the Bloodshed the
unnecessary Bloodshed to end okay my
assessment on the situation might
deviate from uh you know NATO uh like
blood to Thirsty NATO Defenders or
whatever they feel like we shouldn't
even be doing anything in Ukraine no I
don't nothing no no I don't I think you
don't think so no I think that of course
there's a a necessary intervention that
that must happen I'm not saying that at
all I mean I [__] raised hundreds of
thousands of dollars for Ukrainian
refugees like I'm sorry this is well
we're just silly [__] thing that like
not from you but I hear so much from
[__] online
suck my dick you know so you do you
believe that America's actions in
Ukraine are are the right ones I think
that America's actions to a certain
degree in Ukraine is understandable it's
it's reasonable certainly whether
Ukrainian people want but I think
America's interest in Ukraine is not
genuine it's not genuine emancipation
it's more so a continuation of the
Bloodshed well it was demonstrated not
by me but by American politicians like
Chris Murphy who have openly said on the
record that for five percent of our
military budget we've been able to
[__] a foreign adversary's military
budget without a single American Service
member dying in the process I would say
that that is profoundly successful what
are we doing in Ukraine we're sending
our refurbished old weapons and weapon
systems the Ukraine we have to replenish
those weapon systems it's a never-ending
cycle okay because there well the reason
I ask is because there seems to be a
somewhat of a
a sentiment in the left circles or are
social I don't know how to even describe
it I don't know but that that the the
proxy war people say in Ukraine is war
no I know but they're saying we
shouldn't be supporting Ukraine and the
whole thing yeah I I should just take
Ukraine no I can't speak for other uh I
can't speak for other leftists I don't
know what the [__] they say but plenty
of those people also despise me and say
that I'm like not pushing Z or whatever
so it doesn't [__] I heard I thought
I heard Richard Wolff have some kind of
thing like that I don't I can't speak
convertible either there's disagreements
that I have with Richard wolf you're
down with what's happening down you're
down I'm not down with what's happening
in Ukraine because I want the Bloodshed
to end and the only way to do that is by
bringing China to the table bringing
America to the table we think the real
actors here Ukraine should make some uh
secessions to Russia I think the
original six-point plan uh that was a
continuation of the Minx uh Accords that
were tried twice and failed twice
um would be a far preferable situation
than like endless Bloodshed over you
know inches of territory where you know
people are being [__] slaughtered
ukrainians would describe it as inches
of territory
wait what do you mean well you're saying
they're fighting over inches of
territory it's just saying in the
context of how stagnated the war has
become like that the back and forth has
pretty much ground to a halt at this
point and this is what I mean it's like
a very cynical interpretation of what
I'm trying to say it is interest of
territory physically when we when we
speak about it but you're I guess a lot
I think Ukrainian people get angry when
they hear you talk about it because they
I that's understandable I mean they get
like you're
support right they understandably want
that and they want more than that they
also wanted Article Five they wanted
full NATO protections and NATO Nations
they don't they don't like that you say
that they should secede territory to a
fascist Invader it's not even a
secession of territory it's like prior
agreements that neither party is held on
to the real Ukrainian criticism in this
situation comes from people who say well
Hassan how can you say that when Russia
has not held on to their obligations and
that is true Russia has not held on to
their side of the bargain on the men's
Accords but neither has Ukraine and my
point is
ensuring that with it International
cooperation about that Accord what is
that the Minsk Accords were
um so this again goes deep into [__]
history and you can't always say like oh
I don't know the history so I don't know
and then repeat like mainstream media
propaganda you know well I don't okay I
don't know anything thing about it
Ukraine as a nation state has uh has
even predated or some form of like
Ukraine has predated even the Russian uh
nation state or the the Russian Empire I
guess uh and it's nation state
development project has always hinged on
uh excising Russian influence however
under the USSR Ukraine uh which was
called the Ukraine originally which just
means like the Border okay was seen as
uh I mean what had plenty of Russian uh
sympathy uh sympathetic people that
lived in the Eastern regions
um and that sympathy only grew the
further east you went the closer you got
to current uh existing Russian territory
now that is no longer the case make no
mistake I'm not saying that at all it's
and that is no longer the case almost
entirely due to Russia's actions in that
area like blowing the [__] out of car
give is going to make sure is a fast
this way to make sure that there is no
sympathies for your government whatso
[__] ever ever again for the rest of
your life so
that's all gone away
um but originally the contention was LPR
and DPR through Russian influence and
this is the Ukrainian assessment of the
situation these two areas uh wanted
autonomy and were getting backed by the
Russian government and Western
involvement that wanted to keep Ukraine
in the sphere of the West did not want
to give the actual protective
assurements or assurances sorry to
Ukraine but wanted to play the the
delicate balance of like saying you know
what yeah maybe we'll get you in the
NATO maybe we'll get you in the NATO
with no real interest in getting them
into NATO maybe we'll get you into the
EU
what how did Ukraine violate their
agreement
um there was mass shelling on both sides
uh like back and forth
uh no back and forth shelling that has
been happening since uh
2004. okay
13 or 14 000 uh people dying Okay so
so that is so at the time there was a
agreement called the Minsk agreements
there were two versions of this which
neither side agreed upon which meant
that uh LPR and DPR would still remain
under Ukraine but would have autonomy
okay and Ukraine understandably did not
want this because that would mean that
Russia would have an outsized control on
Ukrainian Affairs and Ukraine politics
which it already did through Russian
loyalist leadership that they had that
was uh that was obviously squashed
because there's always been this back
and forth between Western influence in
Ukraine wanting to move them into the
Western sphere of influence and Eastern
influence Russian influence in Ukraine
which wanted to maintain uh Ukraine's
status and and wanted to change
Ukrainian Affairs okay so they were both
attacking each other and you think the
attacks were equally provocative and
again I don't know anything about it I
think that I think that uh uh the the
this was another instance of of proxy
war 100 okay like there are people who
who uh wanted to be a part of Russia and
um the
at the end of the day though like the
reaction from the Ukrainian government
to that was understandable they wanted
to protect their own interests they
wanted to protect their own borders they
wanted to protect their hegemony and uh
and and National Security interests
but there's a difference between like
what they did in Crimea for example and
what they did with LPR and DPR what do
they do in Crimea there there was a
referendum people say it was [__]
referendum it was under gunpoint which
is understandable to say that because
that is what happened in Crimea but
Russian territorial claims the Crimea uh
as a like Russian territorial claims
that Crimea had more historical
prescience and and and the highest level
of support uh for uh you know uh a
Russian expansionist uh policies in
Crimea specifically because of its a
military base uh that the Russian
military operated out of okay and what
did Ukraine do in that situation they
cut the water supply they immediately
[__] broke a dam a USSR era Dam that
was offering Supply like water water for
the Crimean citizens that they said they
you know care talk about that recently
no that Dam has been destroyed when
Russia invaded Ukraine but essentially I
wanted to clarify they cut Crimea off
and and not in the same way that they uh
wanted to deal with LPR and DPR I wanted
to clarify your position yes because it
seems like there's a lot of confusion so
it's good to clarify you do support this
will not clarify my position in the eyes
of people who want to say that I'm like
anti-ukaine people are still going to
[__] yell at me but you said that you
believe what America is doing in Ukraine
is right
I believe that Ukraine has a right to
emancipation what America should do in
Ukraine is is offer security commitments
and assurances and only and you can only
get that by arriving at a at a table
where you don't [__] uh destroy the
the bargaining chips and instead allow
the original security commitments to
continue hey I don't know what you mean
by that you mean Ukrainian envoys and
Russian envoys got together in Antalya
and put a 15-point security plan
together uh as they were negotiating in
terms of a ceasefire agreement Russia
they we need to get them and I mean that
it's not that easy I would assume well
it there was uh moves that were being
made to arrive at them like a year ago
kind of like a fascist leader is yes
Putin's interests are are take the whole
thing Putin's interests certainly are
nationalistic uh there's obviously
material benefits to Ukraine because
Ukraine would be a competitor to to
Russia as far as yeah should go to the
table and make concessions to the
Russians I think the ukrainians went to
the table and made concessions to the
Russians originally and it was actually
a very clever move by zielinski to like
for example uh push the Crimean
referendum 15 years down the line in
order to not uh deliberate on that
aspect right now because ukrainians want
Crimea back as well they want LPR and
DPR to be Ukrainian
um and zielinski knew that that was
going to be an like impossible thing to
deal with because he's right now on the
one hand you have ukrainians with re
with interest in emancipation ridding uh
the Russian Scourge from their uh
borders uh and and taking back all of
their territory from Russia which
includes Crimea as well so he has a
delicate balance where he has to make
sure that those guys are not pissed off
uh and and you know overthrow him and
then like you know
or or that America somehow gets involved
and overthrows them while simultaneously
ending the war I'm assuming where people
get mad at you
is just the suggestion that Ukraine
should make concessions to an aggressive
fascist Invader because as we know you
know the European fascists Invaders
um people often wonder they don't stop
if we made consent if we didn't make
concessions to Hitler would the would
the war happen people wonder that
yeah um there's a there's a difference
of like um there's a difference of
talking pre-World War II and post-world
War II because we do have mutually
assured nuclear uh destruction I was
about to say it's so unfortunately the
nukes change all the calculus so that's
the difference there and that's a very
significant one because Article 5
dictates that like any kind of NATO
nation that Russia tries to attack okay
because NATO was developed against
Russia USSR communism it was an
anti-communist institution of itself
um immediately means that all other
nations according to Article Five are
drawn into war with a nuclear superpower
like Russia right so there's a
difference plus one other aspect of this
is that like they Russia kind of showed
its ass and it's uh it's its
capabilities and where those
capabilities end as far as ground war
goes which is the reason why you see
Finland and Sweden which previously had
long-held neutrality not like direct
agreements but long-held neutrality uh
uh I wouldn't say treaties because it's
not an official treaty but just like
didn't join NATO and understand
immediately join NATO why because they
realized they don't have any [__]
power what are they gonna do go to
Finland get the [__] out of here they
can't even they can't take over Ukraine
they said it was gonna be a day they
suck they don't have the power so also I
don't know the exact name of it but I
know Ukraine surrendered their nuclear
weapons which one of the best things you
can help worst things you could do never
give up the nukes like in terms of like
a humanistic uh a political move it's
bad but like as a as a human something
that yeah I mean obviously we should get
rid of nukes some say Ukraine had no way
of utilizing those nukes because like
the controls were the control mechanism
was in the USSR so in Moscow but
um but you still shouldn't have uh given
your Nuclear So yeah so your your point
is that we should never they should
never have done that no I think we'd be
looking in a very different world if uh
for ukrainians at least with the benefit
of a hindsight how could you say that I
mean I don't think they would get right
now if they had nukes right I mean well
if you have nukes you don't get invaded
that's just kind of how it works anyway
we made a guarantee to them that you you
give up your nukes and we will got your
back
and so I do feel like that's a pretty
important agreement to uphold
I mean what
you're talking about American promises
to Ukraine in exchange for surrendering
their new surrendering our news uh
America America never like actually
followed through on any of their
promises America's still not following
technically their Promises of Defending
Ukraine they're just giving ukrainians
weapons Ukraine is currently sitting in
a very unique position that I see uh
happen in the same cycle of violence in
the Middle East all the [__] time
America goes to a militant group and
says hey we're going to give you weapons
you want autonomy specifically Kurds
right you think every country should
have a nuclear bomb
if you have a nation-state you have to
have a [__] nuke otherwise America
will come and [__] you up so yeah every
nation should have a nuke I think either
every nation has a nuke or none of them
have it and I would obviously want none
of the Nations to have it unless this is
why I was in support of the Iranian
denuclearization agreement I thought
that was good which you know Donald
Trump [__] up oops I believe an
individual citizen in this country has a
right to own do you believe every person
that's the Socialist Vision yes I think
everyone should have a nuclear bomb
that's the only equality that we can
really everyone should have a nuclear
Silo in their garage
so okay in short you support Ukraine
what what the Allied powers are doing to
support them is is right
no because America's interest in Ukraine
is not one that is genuine America's
interest in Ukraine is just I don't care
about withering I don't know but that's
everybody I'm asking what you think
because no America's interest in Ukraine
is incredibly important what do you
think is the right thing to do in
Ukraine I told you what I think the
right thing to do and I asked
declaration you setting up the deal
instead of [__] up the deal that
Ukraine had with Russia by uh you know
Boris Johnson [__] showing up in the
middle of that going to Kiev directly
dude do you think what's happening there
is right if not why
do I think what's happening Allied you
asked me a question I answer it and then
you move on to something because you I I
ask you I'm telling you what I want
Allied Powers is what they're doing
they're right you said no but I just got
done having this whole conversation
where you said yeah I think what the
Allied powers are doing as far as like
uh as far as giving weapons to Ukraine
with no end in sight because they see it
as a great way to [__] like a great
way to continue the the harm done to a
weak Russia that they can simultaneously
claim is like really [__] powerful is
is only going to continue this war
rather than try to [__] Implement
security commitments and and get to a a
uh a unilateral agreement or a bilateral
agreement where uh and not just [__]
Russia and Ukraine but like bring China
to the table and put an end like do a
ceasefire and put an end of this war is
infinitely better for Ukraine in
Ukrainian development Ukrainian economy
Ukrainian citizens not [__] dying uh
senselessly under a uh artillery
shelling campaign that's literally
happening you know what's really [__]
insane about this Russia is getting
artillery shells from North Korea and
America is giving uh America's telling
South Korea to give artillery shells the
Ukraine it's [__] nuts both sizes
shelling each other shells but it's so
stupid Ukraine is now also using uh
depleted uranium uh as well on its own
[__] soil okay so you're going to
have damage implications is that that's
gonna happen helping Ukraine is good but
that Ukraine needs to be more willing to
make concessions not just Ukraine are no
allies need to be more willing to uh to
to some in certain instances even push
Ukraine to make uh understandable uh
concessions with because the idea of
land what like giving up land not giving
up land no it's not giving up land but
it's pushing a referendum 15 years into
the future for Crimea is a really solid
uh middle of the ground approach
zielinski's own team actually put
forward which I thought was great do you
think zelenski is a provocateur no oh
should I have a doctor's appointment
what the [__] oh I'm just asking because
that's a position I'm not I'm not saying
that you ever said that
what you said it like I've said it no no
I was just getting your opinion on it
just because I've heard people say that
and I just do it I just checking your
opinion on it no what time is it at Lena
it's at it's at two that's my last part
though basically no I don't think
zelinski is a provocative or what like a
bad faith actor no I think zelenski is
uh certainly a self-interested
politician who uh definitely wants a man
salvation that's literally yeah meaning
his well anyway yeah no he want he wants
Russia to no longer have uh control over
Ukrainian territories which is perfectly
reasonable he also has to strike a
delicate balance because as I correctly
pointed out when the invasion first
happened whenever an era dentist or
imperialist power makes a move on
another Nation you embolden some of the
most reactionary forces and they are
seen as liberators because in that
moment they are the liberators the ones
who have the violent means to to push
back are going to be seen as protectors
that only grows nationalistic hyper
nationalistic sentiment minute and that
is never productive that is never good
it's not good for workers rights that's
not good for uh future prospects of
Ukraine and I think that that blowback
uh who knows what's going to happen but
is is terrifying I have to leave bro all
right but it's wonderful I thank you for
going so long how long have you been
going no you know who needs to leave
three hours Vladimir Putin I need to
leave those people alone hey
brothers I know that's controversial but
he's gotta leave this is probably our
most our longest episode and we did it
not even mentioning a single Uh current
event uh we did mention that Rupert
Murdoch died
um that turned out to be misinformation
that we were spreading but no I said is
he dead okay
he's not dead not yet yet
not yet
okay he's getting up there this was a
good conversation was that good did you
do you feel like uh I'm uh I'm a [__]
anti-American charlatan who's bad faith
no I I think your foreign policies after
talking them out is they're all like
completely defensible
um and and and good positions on the
point of socialism I can say like well I
I have a deeper understanding of it now
I I I do still believe that
it seems more mystical and no you want
marks you want Marx's Lenin is kleinus
thought uh which is socialism with
capitalist characteristics yes and
ultimately that is what I want and
ultimately
we agree almost entirely and if you're
mad about that you're dumb yeah all
right dumb idiot I have to pee really
bad I don't know you're watching this
and you're angry you're a stupid
freaking Gotham man dumbass
no I thought that was good I thought
that was good I think so unless you're
Ukrainian then you have a then I mean
they have a right at least yeah no for
sure I understand our Taiwanese or
Tibetan I understand they have a right
to be angry I'm just saying I I I get it
you're an armchairs Warriors
I can't wait for it I can't wait for it
yeah so many so many people from
Virginia Langley uh writing about how
they've been living in Taiwan for 25
years right like those uh no I I thought
that was a good faith conversation I
thought it was fantastic I thought it
was good to um and it was good for me to
kind of explore
it's the classic like uh uh Donald Trump
my people yearn for Freedom please glass
Iran uh take that you hear from uh you
know people living on American soil
thank you the only way to save Iran is
by glassing it thank you
all right I have to pee so bad that's
what Ian said oh thanks bro see you next
week bye everybody
[Music]
foreign